Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với có học
cách xem miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số
25 lập trình vba trong excel các bạn chú
ý cuối bài học mình sẽ có người cái ví
dụ mẫu một số ví dụ sẽ có phai thực hành
nhá mình sẽ để cái link tải file thực
hành trong phần mô tả phía dưới video
tốt nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn vừa
theo dõi và thực hành cùng mình nhá như
các bạn biết thì ý Excel là một phần mềm
bảng tính vô cùng hữu dụng và mạnh mẽ
được dùng ở mọi ngành nghề mọi đối tượng
nếu bạn chỉ biết sử dụng các chức năng
có sẵn của Excel thì công việc của bạn
sẽ được làm cách thủ công chậm chạp vậy
Làm thế nào để cải thiện hiệu suất công
việc biến công việc của bạn từ thủ công
thành tự động thì đi về Excel chính là
câu trả lời cho bạn Vậy thì vi B Excel
là gì khi nào thì nên học lập trình vba
và học lập trình vba trong Excel có thể
làm được những gì ưu nhược điểm ra làm
sao thì hôm nay mình sẽ trả lời cho bạn
cho
Xem tivi được viết tắt là khi rùa basic
for application là một ứng dụng được
nhúng trong Excel để thực hiện các thao
tác nhất định của bạn khi bạn muốn thực
hiện chức năng nào đó thay vì làm bằng
tay thì bạn chỉ cần chọn ra các lệnh
được kích hoạt sẵn từ trong Excel để tự
động thực hiện kết quả sẽ xuất hiện
trong thời gian rất nhanh và số liệu
chính xác bởi vì khi nào thì nên học lập
trình vba trong excel các bạn thấy học
vba Excel nay khi các bạn thấy mình thao
tác thủ công quá nhiều công việc lặp đi
lặp lại nhiều lần phải mất quá nhiều
thời gian cho nó Bạn thấy công việc của
mình rất chậm và bạn cảm thấy công việc
nhàm chán đó chính là lúc mà bạn sẽ học
vba Vậy học xong đi đây có thể làm được
gì sẽ làm được tất cả những công việc
mỗi xe có thể làm được như là lưu trữ
danh sách lên kế hoạch phân tích dữ liệu
phát triển các biểu đồ từ nguồn dữ liệu
lưu trữ có thể tự xây dựng các chương
trình bảng biểu trong Excel dù với mục
đích nào thì tất cả đều là biến các thao
tác của bạn trở nên
vì vậy ưu điểm của BB Excel là gì live
access thì luôn thực hiện các công việc
một cách chính xác thực hiện các công
việc nhanh hơn nhiều so với bạn ngồi bấm
máy tính đặc biệt là các công việc và
người khác không thể điều này có thể làm
cho bạn trở lên nổi tiếng và tiết kiệm
thời gian một cách tối đa Tất nhiên
nhược điểm của vba Excel là bạn phải có
khả năng lập trình thì trong bài hôm nay
mình rất cố gắng hướng dẫn cho các bạn
một cách chi tiết và đơn giản nhất dưới
góc nhìn của một người đi làm như mình
để bắt đầu bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ
đi vào một cái ví dụ cụ thể đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ bấm An F11 này đấy vì sau khi các
bạn bấm ăn F11 định thì nó sẽ hiện ra
cái cửa sổ Đây là một cái môi trường để
phát lập trình VB nhé để các bạn sẽ tích
lũy và cái sít một này này Đấy ký ngay
bên phải này nó sẽ hiện một cái môi
trường để bạn lập trình nha Rồi các bạn
gọi cho mình sắp này Ví dụ mình ghi là
xây Hello quạt đóng ngoặc đơn lặng trong
các bạn enter thì kệ em sắp này nó sẽ tự
động nó sẽ thêm vào cái
khi nghe các bạn Hiện tượng gãy đỡ xuống
dòng nhất bây giờ các bạn sẽ bấm em s
các bạn có thể bấm cardspace thì nó sẽ
tự động nó gợi nhắc các câu lệnh mà bắt
đầu bằng chữ s để mình sẽ dùng cái msg
Bắc này là lại có cách ra các bạn ghi là
gì Halloween đấy các bạn sau Các bạn bấm
vào nút hình tam giác màu xanh để chạy
chương trình nhé Đấy nó sẽ hiện ra một
cái thông báo là Hello world mà mình vừa
nãy nhập vào đây là một cái ví dụ rất là
kinh điển của mọi ngôn ngữ lập trình đấy
hầu như khi có bạn học một ngôn ngữ lập
trình Những thì nó sẽ giới thiệu của các
bạn cái ví dụ là hiện cái chữ halliwell
ra màn hình để đoạn tích ok trong trường
hợp mà các bạn không muốn hiện cái thông
báo vừa xong lại thì bạn có thể xóa đi
các bạn gõ là diện theo của 1,1 quạt
đóng ngoặc đơn lại bằng các bạn mở khóa
két nhé Hello mua lại có đóng và ghép
lại với các bạn bấm
trà xanh để chạy chương trình để tìm các
bạn sẽ thấy là ở cái ô hạng 1 cột 1 đây
này Nó hiện ra chữ halliwell ở đây mình
sẽ giải thích qua cho các bạn nhé cái
chữ sắc và em sắp đây là mở đầu và kết
thúc của một chương trình nhé còn xây
Hello là tên một chương trình thì một
chương trình bao giờ cũng có mở đầu và
kết thúc và tên của một chương trình xây
Hello tên tiếng Anh nghĩa là nói xin
chào đấy thì cái chỗ mà xe lại mở ngoặc
11 Tức là mình sẽ gán ở cái ô ở hàng 1
cột 1 bằng cái chữ Halloween đấy hoặc
mình có thể đổi chữ Hello này bằng lái
xe hạng nhất để các bạn bạn F5 hoặc là
bấm Plus vào sang tam giác để chạy là
đấy thì cái chữ này nó sẽ đổi thành ra
Excel Đây là cái ví dụ đầu tiên để mình
làm quen với chương trình nhé các bạn có
thể đóng lại tiếp theo để sử dụng video
hiệu quả thì mình cần kéo cái thẻ
developer ra ngoài Excel này thì để làm
được này các bạn đã biết sau nhé các bạn
có thể nhảy chuột phải bất kỳ và cái
vùng điều khiển
ở nhà này nhá Ví dụ mình nháy qua đây
không có bạn chọn để cắt tamara biệt để
nó sẽ hiện ra một cái cửa sổ mới thì các
bạn nhìn ở bên phải này nó có chữ
developer ở đây này nếu bạn nào mà chưa
thích như thế này chẳng hạn thì bạn sẽ
tích vào đây Thằng các bạn thích ok đấy
thì nó xuất hiện cái thẻ thì lúc tôi ra
đây sau đó các bạn thích vào cái trẻ này
các bạn chọn vào visualbasic đấy thì nó
sẽ cũng diện với cửa sổ như vừa xong
mình bấm phím tắt là An F11 để để thì
thay vì bấm ba lớp 11 thì các bạn có thể
vào thẻ developer và các bạn thích và ví
dụ Magic Ok ở đây mình xin giới thiệu
các bạn một cái cửa sổ mới gọi là i mizz
đấy trong trường hợp mà bạn nào không
thấy cửa sổ này ví dụ là mình đóng đi
nhé thì các bạn làm như sau bạn vào thẻ
view này trong cái ví dụ music nhé Còn
các bạn chọn inverness Windows hoặc phím
tắt là controller đấy thì nó sẽ tạo với
cửa sổ đây cái cửa sổ đây để làm việc gì
để các bạn có thể test từng cái câu lệnh
đơn hoặc các bạn có thể in để chạy được
bất kỳ hạt nha bây Ví dụ mình hỏi hỏi
chấm 1
Ừ đấy thì nó sẽ trả về kết quả là hai
hoặc các bạn có thể gõ cái câu lệnh cho
này Ví dụ mình có các loại trên Excel
này Ví dụ ở hàng hay cột 3 này hiệu bằng
các bạn mở ngoặc và gái sen hạt nhé các
bạn bấm enter đấy thì nó sẽ gắn ở cái
hàng hay cột 3 cái chữ cái xe này không
cần phải trong một cái cú pháp của cái
bắt đầu và kết thúc của chương trình
nhân của bạn nó sẽ thực hiện từng lệnh
Đơn Một đấy là cái cửa sổ inverness lên
ok ở đây mình sẽ thu nhỏ của Excel lại
cho bạn sẽ nhìn nhất để kéo cái này rộng
ra bên này là Excel còn bên này là cái
cửa sổ liệu lập trình nhé đầu tiên mình
sẽ giới thiệu với bạn một số khái niệm
cơ bản trong vbiz đầu tiên là khái niệm
sale thì như các biết xe thì được kết
hợp của hàng và cột thì trong Excel
Excel 2007 giờ đi các bạn ấn cần cho mũi
tên xuống nhất để nó sẽ xuống ngân hàng
cuối cùng này thì nó sẽ có hơn một triệu
hàng cơ các bạn Tấn Cường
Ừ để nó về cái sao A1 ở đây này tương tự
các bạn ấn cần chung nội tiết xong phải
nó sẽ sang cái cột Cuối Cùng Ở đây là
cột xsd thì bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ là hơn
16.000 Cột như vậy excel của mình sẽ có
là hơn một triệu hàng và hơn 16.000 Cột
để và gắn giá trị cho xem cái gọi chỉ
cần có theo công thức các bạn có thể sao
này ví dụ các bạn gán là hàng hay cột
một lúc bảng Hello Đợi tí bạn thấy em
đây hàng hay của một bằng Hello hoặc các
bạn có thể ví dụ Các bạn đang ở cái gì
đây đây hàng năm và cột b là cuộc số 2B
mình muốn nhảy sang cái hạt 11 thì rõ gì
các mặt họ Seo của điện 1,1 chấm select
để gọi enter một cái đấy thì nó sẽ nhảy
về cái xe này A1 ở đây tiếp theo mình sẽ
giới thiệu các bạn về Ngốc Xít đây giả
sử các bạn có thể thêm axit là hạt nhân
tiếp một thứ 2 thứ 3 thế bạn thấy ở bên
này sau đó sẽ có
ý tưởng này ở đây là đang là Sĩ Ma bây
giờ mình muốn chuyển nhanh ít một để các
bạn làm việc nhé thì bạn làm như sau bạn
gõ Thiện xít này đã qua mở ngoặc đơn ra
còn màu kép có hai cách cách thứ nhất là
các bạn gõ đúng cái tên thì các bạn ở
đây là ship 1 chẳng hạn nha sheet1 này
có đóng ngoặc kép lại đồng các đơn lại
chấm select để chọn enter thì nó sẽ
chuyển sang là cái xịt một là thích
select rất là ship một là các xít để
mình đang làm việc đấy Cách thứ hai là
gì ạ bây Ví dụ mình quay lại Mình thích
ca sĩ 3b muốn chuyển rất ít một em mình
có thể gõ là việc mình gọi là xít này
hãy mở ngoặc 1 thôi tức là một Đây là số
thứ tự thì biết thích một này nằm ở đầu
tiên thì mình vẫn là xít 1.6 ex để gọi
enter một cái có thể nó lại chuyển được
sĩ một rồi Hoặc là các bạn rõ việc xếp
thứ Hai nhé chấm Shake thì nó lại quay
về cái sĩ hay để đã xin làm việc
anh quá có thể đổi tên nha ví dụ mình
muốn đổi tên cái Spa là gãy xe đó thì
các bạn sẽ là điện sheet mở ngoặc 3 đấy
chấm nêm không các bạn bằng bà ví dụ là
gái xem nhé đấy bọn đóng ngoặc lại con
enter đấy còn thêm cái spa này được đổi
tên thành gái Cell rồi đấy là cách mình
làm việc với xít thì mình sẽ gọi tên
ship và mình sẽ lách là lựa chọn và chấm
nêm là đặt tên còn rất là nhiều cái tính
năng khác thì trong các phép Ví dụ ở
phía cuối video mình sẽ hướng dẫn cho
các bạn chi tiết nhé Đây là các bạn hiểu
về sheet tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu
các bạn về bút chẳng hạn như bây giờ
mình đang làm việc trên Facebook một này
Bây giờ mình muốn tạo 1 cái file mới các
bạn và file này Các bạn bấm lưu lại Ví
dụ mình chọn một cái gốc mới thì thuốc
mới này có tên là bút hay Facebook hay
là Facebook mà mình đang thích vào thì
nó gọi là Active anh tin Facebook với
mình gõ là việc mình gõ là theo của 1
A1 Mà mạng gì bằng gái xem Theo các bạn
thì nó sẽ gán vào cái bụp hay là cái bút
một ở đây kết quả là sự giảm Facebook
hay tại vì Facebook hay đang là cái lúc
làm việc để gọi enter một cái đấy bởi vì
các bạn thích vào Facebook một này không
các bạn hãy chạy lại này thì nó sẽ gán
Vào Facebook một để Tức là cái lệnh này
nếu mà Khuyết không có chút hoặc là quốc
tí nào thì nó sẽ mặc định là nó sẽ chỉ
vào cái Facebook nào đang làm việc rất
là đang Active và cái gốc sĩ đang ấy
tiếp đấy Đấy là cách để mình truy nhập
ngũ cũng nhắn bây giờ lại mình mở
Facebook ai lên bây giờ giả sử mình mình
đang là cái Úc hay này đang Active bây
giờ mình muốn truy cập vào cái nút một
thì mình làm như thế nào thì bạn phải
chỉ cần thêm câu lệnh ở quốc phụ kiện
Macbook các mở mạng có lẽ các bạn mở
ngoặc đơn này là Diệt Tên của game này
là bốc 1 - nạn thế nhá mục
có một cái bạn đóng ngoặc kép đóng ngoặc
đơn giản chấm điện Tê Các bạn chửi em
cái bốc một là cái ship hay nó đang làm
việc đúng ạ thì bạn sẽ chấm chấm than mở
ngoặc có thể gõ số 2 rất là ở thứ tự thứ
hai đúng không ạ chấm gì Ví dụ mình dán
là sao hàng thứ hai cột một đấy bằng
đang là gái xe luôn cái chữ này là xin
chào bạn nhé bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại gọi
enter đấy mặc dù cái bút hay đang lại
tiếp nhưng mà nó vẫn truy cập được và bé
búp một đấy thế để truy cập vào một cái
bút mà không phải chết thì các bạn nhớ
là quan phải thêm Facebook để tiếp theo
là bạn thao tác trên cái sim nào thì bạn
có thông tin là gì đấy đây chấm xem một
là xin chào đấy Đây là cách truy nhập
Đến World Cup và Quốc sheet về mình đóng
vai để lại mình không cần dùng nữa Okay
tiếp theo Vì sẽ giới thiệu với các bạn
một số khái niệm khác thì đầu tiên sẽ
biến
em về biến thì các bạn chú ý nhé các bạn
cứ tưởng tượng biến như là một cái hộp
các bạn có thể lực được quả bóng này các
bạn có thể đựng được rau củ quả hoặc các
bạn có thể được đồ chơi đấy thì biến
cũng như vậy biết thì các bạn có thể dán
được bằng giá trị này hoặc bằng giá trị
khác mà tùy các bạn muốn biến thì có
giới hạn từ giá trị nhỏ nhất đến giá trị
lớn nhất của nó thôi tương tự như vậy
thì Hồ Việt thì cũng có rất là nhiều
loại ví dụ hộp bằng nhựa của bằng thủy
tinh hay là Hộp to hợp nhỏ thì biến cũng
vậy biến thì có rất là nhiều kiểu biết
thì đây mình đã đi cho bạn một số cái
kiểu biến chính và cái khoảng giá trị từ
nhỏ nhất đến lớn nhất mà nó có thể làm
đầu tiên ở đây là kiểu interior thế là
kiểu Nguyên kiểu số thì có giá trị từ
-32768 đến ba 2.767 tương tự là Tiểu
Long là kiểu cũng là kiểu số thì có giá
trị lớn hơn là tự - 2 tỷ đến 2 tỷ cho
kiểu sinh kiểu lắc bồ đấy các bạn có thể
tham khảo ở đây nhá Có thể là triệu
Facebook là
Đây là kiểu lên Tức là những cái đối
tượng của Excel hoặc là cái kiểu variant
kiểu variant này là một cái kiểu mà bất
kỳ là cũng được Tức là mình chưa xác
định rõ ràng thì mình cứ đặt đó là
variant nhắn Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ làm một
cái ví dụ về biến như các bạn nhé Đây
vẫn xóa đây này Ở đây mình gõ là gì cả
chửi nha các bạn có thể viết cốt ở trên
trực tiếp VSIP này Hoặc là các bạn sẽ
biết Cốt và môđun chỉ Thông thường thì
mình sẽ biết cốt trong môđun bởi vì thì
các bạn biết cốt ở chiến sĩ này mà các
bạn xóa đi thì nó sẽ bị mất cốt của các
bạn đấy còn các bạn biết cốt ở trên cố
định thì nó sẽ đi theo cái file của các
bạn luôn chiều khi các bạn Xóa thấy file
đấy thì nó mới mất cốt truyện để tạo một
cái mô đun mình rất cố định thì bạn nháy
chuột phải vào bất kỳ vị trí nào ở đây
các bạn nháy chuột phải vào đây quan
chọn Insert để qua chọn môđun đây là
không có kích cỡ cái mô đun này để bên
này còn cái cốc nhé ví dụ các bạn gõ
được việc sắp này ví dụ là Excel cấp tốc
tại hạ thứ nhất mình đặt tên là Excel
cấp tốc á
ăn mặc đơn lại còn enter thì vẫn chú ý
nha cái tên của chương trình là phải
biết liền không được có dấu cách và
không được có kí tự đặc biệt thì nó có
một số quy tắc nhất định thì bạn cũng
không quá lo lắng nó bạn chỉ cần nhớ là
các bạn đặt tên có ý nghĩa và không có
dấu cách là được lại Ok Ví dụ mình để
thay các biến thì bạn dùng cái cú pháp
là zin này sao là tên biến Ví dụ mình
ghi là biến Lê Hiển hạn nhé s là triệu
biến là gì Ví dụ interior là số nguyên
nhân thế đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ đặt Ví dụ
mình đặt y = 5 lại cho mình cảm thực
hiện sao của 1,1 bằng y nặng thế nhá với
các bạn chạy chương trình đấy Bạn thấy
không thì ở đây là sẽ là bằng năm Bây
giờ mình đổi y = 7 giới hạn thiện đây
mình chạy nhé đấy thì ở đây nó là do vậy
thì tiếp theo với mình sẽ giới thiệu các
bạn về hết nhá một cái cái liền cũng rất
là hay dùng trong Excel và trong vba thì
lên là gì nên có thể là nhiều xe Liên
khoa học là một siêu đơn cũng có thể là
gọi là nên lấy ví dụ mình gõ là thẻ bên
này các bạn mở ngoặc ra Ví dụ gì ạ A1
lại đoạn 2 chấm đến B3 hãy gọi đóng
ngoặc kép đóng ngoặc đơn lại mà bằng
viện bằng gái xe lại có em thơ cảm thấy
thì nó sẽ nhá là từ A1 đến B ba = gái
xem đây là một kết quả xe liên tiếp hoặc
có thể là một xe không hơn Ví dụ mình gõ
là diện lên nên có gì các bạn mở ngoặc
ra là a a 5 đến hạn nhé đấy các bạn đóng
ngoặc kép dấu ngoặc đơn lại bằng gì bằng
xin chào lấy gọi theo Đây chỉ là A5 bằng
xin chào rồi thì lúc này nên cũng là một
Ô thôi Đấy cách khai báo lên nữa là rẻ
lên của ví dụ 2 xe nhắc ví dụ tình gán à
teo ví dụ là hàng 7 cột hay để quạt đóng
ngoặc đại để xong Seo 1 phẩy xe thứ 2 là
diện hàng 8
Tôi muốn điện hạ thế nhất gái chọn dán
bằng điện bằng Hello Được hạn thế nhé để
cậu enter đây là hàng 7 cột 2 đến hàng 8
cột 4 bằng Hello các bạn có thể là chấm
chấm c cũng được lấy ví dụ phân tích một
kiểu khác bất kỳ nhé Ở đây mình đi đã
chấm selects đã gọi enter một cái thì
cái vùng này sẽ được select là được lựa
chọn bây giờ để xóa đi thì các bạn có
thể gánh luôn là bằng việc các bạn đóng
mở ngoặc kép luôn thì nó sẽ xóa luôn này
các bạn chú ý là vip em mình không ấn
được không Rất là mình có thể ăn luôn
cái cốc thôi nhưng mình không thể ăn
được cái thao tác và mình đã làm đâu đấy
ví dụ ở đây mình nhắn là Hello Tại em
thì cách xóa đi là mình có thể khai Bằng
đóng và khóa kéo luôn và các bạn có thể
chấm clear này cũng đã xóa điện lại gọi
enter một cái thì cũng là xóa đi rồi đấy
là Heroin có lên thì dùng rất là nhiều
trong Excel thì sau này các cái ví dụ ở
cuối chương trình
Em nói chi tiết hơn về lên cho các bạn
nhé Okay tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu
các bạn làm điều kiện cả hai dùng gọi là
hàm ít thì ở đây mình sẽ đổi vị trí này
là chuyển biến variant nhắc các bạn Ấn
cardspace này Đấy ra đi Ở đây sau đó
mình rất khai báo thì y bằng điện Các
bạn bấm in bút Ví dụ mình muốn nhập vào
cái chữ phút Bắc ra các bạn ấn cardspace
được lợi nhất để các bạn xuống dưới gọi
đến tác nhé hoặc các bạn có thể gọi đầy
đủ luôn là inbox quát mở ngoặc đơn gian
và mở ngoặc kép là nhập một số vào đây
các bạn đóng ngoặc kép bạn đóng ngoặc
đơn lạc lõng enter thì cái lợi inputbox
này nó sẽ hiện ra một cái cửa sổ để qua
nhập một số và vào nó gắn bằng đi luôn
bây giờ mình muốn kiểm tra cái số y
ngược vào là số chẵn hay mẹ nhé mình sẽ
dùng câu lệnh là gì ít này nếu như mà
địa y này mốt hai hoặc bằng 0 ren đấy
thì mình sẽ hiện thông báo là giờ gì ạ
msgbox thì có thể các bạn cardspace là
mình sẽ ghi là gì ạ
[âm nhạc]
ky0 các bạn vàng Mở ngăn kéo ra cách này
là số chẵn Chả thế còn đóng ngoặc kép
lại ở đây y như các bạn và thì gọi phải
có dấu cách đây không ngược lại thì là
gì ạ Nếu mà không phải là Eo tư mà đi mà
mốt hay mà khác không ấy thì là eo thì
bạn sẽ ghi một cái câu lệnh lìa msg
msgbox Chắc chắn conspeed này các bạn và
ngay cả diệt bằng cách ra là số lẻ sẽ
gọi đóng ngoặc kép lại các bạn em tới
các bạn có một câu lệnh ăn ít đấy Ở đây
mình giải thích nhé ít và em ít là bắt
buộc phải đi với nhau ăn ít để báo hiệu
đã kết thúc với hàm ít này các bạn kết
thúc cái câu điều kiện này để con eo là
ngược lại tức là nếu mà y mà không chết
cho hai người vẫn chạy chương trình nhé
ví dụ mình bấm nút màu xanh này thì nó
bảo là nhập một số đề chính là cái chữ
mình ghi là nhập một số đấy Thế bạn Nhập
một số đây ví dụ mình nhận số
Ừ thế nhé với bạn bằng Ok thì nó sẽ báo
là năm là số lẻ tức là gì nó sẽ kiểm tra
cái 5 chia cho 2 này mà khắc không thì
nó sẽ thực hiện kế lệ heo này thì nó sẽ
hiện là Việt năm.khi đây lúc này là năm
mà sao nó thêm với chị là số lệnh vào
đây để về với mình chạy lại nhé Mình
nhập số 6 em hãy nhát các bạn Ok nó ghi
là rẻ 6 là số chẵn ý Tức là cái hàm điều
kiện rẽ nhánh hoặc là cách làm điều kiện
cũng được nhé Thì cái Hà mít này cũng
rất là hay dùng trong video đấy ok hơi
bị xóa cái nhắn tiếp theo mình sẽ giới
thiệu với các bạn 3 vòng lặp thông dụng
mà các bạn hay dùng nhất trong khi đây
đầu tiên sẽ là vòng đặt pho Sau đó vào
nhập vai và cuối cùng là phòng lạc fuik
thì đầu tiên mình sẽ giải thích tại sao
lại dùng vòng nọc Nòng Nọc có nghĩa là
mình sẽ thực hiện 1 cái thao tác lặp đi
lặp lại cứ mỗi lần mình gặp lại thì mình
sẽ kiểm tra điều kiện để thoát khỏi vòng
lặp máy không
mà tại sao lại cần vòng lặp ví dụ Các
bạn muốn nhập vào cái chuỗi từ 1 đến
1000 ảnh khác nhé thì thông thường gặp
sẽ nhập một này nó gọi nhiều thứ hai này
đấy thằng bạn Bôi đen kéo xuống đến
1.000 thì thôi nhé Nếu bạn nhập như thế
thì bạn kéo xuống nhiều rất là bất tiện
đấy và các bạn phải kiểm tra xem đã bằng
1.000 hay không Nếu mà làm đi đây mình
sẽ làm vòng lặp chỉ có một câu lệnh là
xong mình thay vào zimi này interior
nặng thể ngắt qua Tấn cardspace này đến
Tab thì các bạn sẽ dùng vòng lặp kho Này
y = 1 xu ví dụ là 1.000 đúng ạ đấy các
bạn xuống rằng các bạn bấm nách thì cách
cấu trúc này pho tao là nick nghĩa là để
kết thúc vòng lặp kho thì mình sẽ in lại
các bạn gõ Seo Việt mình dán này từ cái
ví dụ mình gắn được Cái ô này nhá thì ở
đây là gì y = 1 thì mình sẽ có thể dán ở
đây là 70 y tức là từ hàng thứ 7 này
cộng y phẩy ở đây là cục thứ ba những
cuộc C là tổ thứ Ba đến ba lại các bạn
sẽ bằng y đã tạo Chỉ cần một cái vòng
lặp for Mac
bây giờ mình bấm nút này để chạy nhất
Đấy con thấy không từ 1 đến 2 và các
loại ấn can trên mũi tên xuống này Đấy
nó sẽ thấy là vào 1000 luôn rất là nhanh
đấy là một cách ví dụ để các bạn hiểu là
gặp chuyện Đây là vòng lặp for nhé tiếp
theo mình sẽ giới thiệu của anh về vòng
lặp có ai hạn nhé Ở đây mình Ví dụ mình
nhập một cái chuỗi các cái số mình dùng
hàng này toàn bộ biết thì giữa 1 và 100
dạng thứ nhất đấy hoặc các bạn nghe được
phải này còn copy nó gọn modem một cái
vùng dữ liệu đây chả thế enter đấy các
bạn xem ra được một cái vùng số liệu ở
đây gọi copy Bình biết value nhất viết
theo Tù Thành vali Ok bây giờ đây là
mình đã có một cái vùng dữ liệu đây rồi
bây giờ giả sử mình muốn tính tổng với
vùng dữ liệu này thì mình sẽ dùng vòng
lặp quay ở đây nhá cá có thể dùng for
được Tức là gửi giấy for mình quét từ
cái hàng thứ 6 đến cái hàng thứ 18 này
nhưng mà cái form nó có một nhược điểm
là các bạn phải biết được cái hàng cuối
cùng đấy hoặc các bạn phải dùng một cái
hà để các bạn biết được làm cuối cùng
em làm quay này thì con không cần biết
rằng cuối cùng mình sẽ làm các bạn ở đây
nhé ví dụ mình viết khách hàng đầu tiên
là hàng thứ 6 đúng không ạ thì bị xe ga
gì y = 6 từ là mình sẽ giá từ cái hàng
bắt đầu lại U16 em trong bạn dùng một
cái vòng đạp điện wife hoài Khi nào
Thiệt mà sell mở ngoặc này high phải
thức là hàng sáu này hành 6 cột 3 thì
hẳn thế nhé cột 3 và khác rộng để các
bạn đóng các bạn cứ khi nào có giá trị
thì mình là đấy Mình không quan tâm và
nó sẽ quét đến cái hàng cuối cùng đấy
còn nhỏ vậy trong mình sẽ kết thúc bằng
cái lệnh ở quê em w là viết tắt của chữ
oai còn em nghĩa kết thúc đẩy cú pháp
của cái vòng lập voi là quay và cuối
cùng là quen thì các bạn chú ý nhất
trước khi mà quen ai bạn đã tăng y lên y
= y + 1 tại sao lại tăng Y hiện tại vì
khi mình làm sau hàng thứ sáu nhé Thì
mình sẽ làm hàng thứ bảy đúng ạ tiếp
theo là hàng thứ 8 thì các câu lệnh y
tăng lên là như vậy ạ đây ví dụ mình
khai báo một cách biến
xe Dream đi + S line điện cái kiểu loa
ngoài nó kèo thiểu số nhưng mà kết quả
giá trị của nó lớn hơn interior thì mình
có thể dán Thiện tầm bằng không nhé Rất
là đầu tiên sẽ tầng không thì ở đây mình
sẽ dán thì tổng này sẽ bằng tổng cộng
lấy cả sao của dì của y phẩy ba trong ví
dụ này mình chỉ cộng là cái cột C lại
thôi nhé Đấy thì mình sử dụng những câu
lệnh này xong Cuối Cùng Mình hiện của
cái thông báo nhé em report này lại tắt
mở khóa ra tổng là hiệu tổng cục C là
thẳng thứ nhất còn hai chấm cách thành
động đóng ngoặc kép lại các bạn và với
cả giá trị tổng ở đây để bây giờ mình
chặt chương trình nhá các bạn bước màu
xanh này đấy thấy tổng cục C là 747b gọi
kiểm tra nhé Đấy tổng ở đây là xong vào
đây là 747 đúng không Ví dụ các bạn muốn
tính tổng cục d này nhá thì bạn chỉ cần
làm theo yêu bố vào đây thôi để về các
bạn
anh lại tổng hữu các đội là tổng cục đê
ở đây Ở đây bị chia đổi ví dụ bình
thường của d mà mình chạy lại nha đấy
thì tổng cục D là 729 mình kiểm tra nhé
Đây để 729 ở dưới này rồi đấy để trong
cho mình muốn + toàn bộ cái cùng dữ liệu
này cơ đấy thì các bạn lại phải dùng một
cái vòng nạp mới để cho một cái biến
được quét từ cái cột đầu tiên đến hết
cuộc cuối cùng này thì tức là lúc nãy
mình phải hai vòng nạp thì một là mình
có thể dùng vào là của ai hoặc là vòng
lặp for thì cũng khá là rắc rối thì tiếp
theo mình sẽ giới thiệu gọi một cái vòng
học gọi là khó ích và cái gọi là
countries is phải một cái tính năng rất
là hay của Tiêu buổi sáng đây nhá thì
mình cứ dùng cách tổng với cả cái in vợ
thì trước tiên thì mình sẽ giới thiệu
các bạn cần Duy gần trước nhau ví dụ bây
giờ mình muốn gánh Excel Ví dụ ở đây là
hành 6 cột 3 nha rất là Cái oc6 đây là
chất dõi tiếp nhé ấy vì mình đang thích
một cái Obi Kỳ ra ngoài vùng dữ liệu này
em muốn biot C6 lại tiết thì bạn gọi
điện sao này ví dụ hành 6 cột 3 hãy chấm
select thì lúc này nó sẽ lựa chọn cái
này trong các rõ rệt các rõ gì Excel này
mail.yahoo.com jerseys China chấm
selects enter một cái thì nó sẽ lựa chọn
toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu này nó chỉ cần
tìm một cái ô trong cái vụ dữ liệu Thôi
thì cái kernel prison nó sẽ lựa chọn
toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu đấy ví dụ Kyo
Active là ưu này chẳng hạn thế nhé Bây
giờ mình chạy cái lệnh này đấy bạn nhé
Thì toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu này được chọn
bất kỳ một cái ô nào đây thôi Thì toàn
bộ cái vùng dữ liệu để lựa chọn các bạn
thích ở tên dòng này có enter để chạy
lại cái lệnh này Đấy rất là hai ạ thì
mình sẽ ứng dụng cái color freeze và cái
Ford để mình làm nhé mày chọn xóa cái
này đi Ví dụ mình thay vào y = biến và
biến gen điện
ở lại là biến gen mình sẽ quét là yêu
mình quét thường cái ô một trong cái này
thì mỗi một ô cũng là một lên đấy thì
mình sẽ khai báo y ở biển lên mấy con rõ
lại phải ích này Đấy câu lệnh là có ích
nha gì ạ in India mình chọn cái vùng này
thì mình có ghi có thể ghi là dị Viettel
theo Viettel ví dụ hành 6 này mới chọn
một xe bất kỳ trong cái vùng dữ liệu này
thôi hành 6 cột 3 thì hạn thế nhá đấy
chấm chấm girl in prison for engineers
các bạn cái thuận tôi cái này không bấm
conscienceless được trong các bạn kết
thúc iPhone này vẫn là lấy chuyện đấy nó
khác với kêu một lệnh ko là gì đó thêm
với chị ích đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ gà tặng
các bảng tổng cộng với cả diện theo là
cậu Mỹ thôi tổng cộng với cả đi đái cuối
cùng mình sẽ hiện với thông báo là
msgbox để Hoặc ra là
vợ chồng của vùng dữ liệu là thông các
bạn Vàng Và với cả biến động ở đây không
có cái đóng ngoặc động về vẫn chạy nhé
được vì xem nào Ở đây ở đây mình thiếu
một chữ R về gọi Các bạn bấm vào nút
vuông này để stop nhá Để mình chạy lại
các bạn bấm vào nút tạo ra màu xanh này
đấy Con có thể tích cho một vố chị đều
chạy được rồi bây giờ có thích rồi đây
đấy thì tận cái cùng dữ liệu của mình là
2747 đây mình kiểm tra các bạn Model anh
hùng dữ liệu đây thấy đó là 247 rồi để
bên các bạn có thể thêm ví dụ mình copy
cái cột này nhá lại mình thế giờ đây đấy
hoặc các bạn có thể thêm với dữ liệu này
lại các bạn có thể mở rộng với vùng dữ
liệu dưới đây thì cái lạnh này nó đều
chạy được nó không quan tâm cái đến cây
hàng cuối cùng và cuối cùng của bạn để
còn chạy thử xem nhé đấy lúc lại tầm
cùng dữ liệu là 4 7 1 1
em kiểm tra nhất đấy còn đấy 4711 này để
như vậy cái currentregion nó hay ở một
chỗ là Việt nó không cần phải biết cái
hàng cuối cùng và cột cuối cùng là bao
nhiêu mà nó vẫn có thể làm được Tức là
nó sẽ quét toàn bộ từ ngô một trong cái
vùng dữ liệu đấy gọi là cơ lần login như
bạn Thúy Nga các bạn phải lựa chọn một
cái ô trong cái vùng dữ liệu đấy xong
các bạn chấm cơ là reason nhá Ok như vậy
mình đã giới thiệu Xong cho các bạn 3
cái vòng nặng là vòng lặp for Mac này
phòng nằm wai và vòng ngực khói cuối
chương trình thì mình sẽ làm rất là
nhiều ví dụ cho bạn để bạn hiểu được là
các khái niệm này cũng như là các bạn có
thể ứng dụng được và trong cái công việc
của các bạn Thực tế thì học qua ví dụ là
cách học mà nhanh nhất để các bạn có thể
tiếp cận được với Ivy Excel thì ở cuối
chương trình mình sẽ làm khá nhiều ví dụ
để các bạn hiểu nhé Okay tiếp theo
chương trình mình sẽ giới thiệu của các
bạn một cái tính năng trong cái thẻ
developer này gọi là record macro đấy à
record lại khá lạc Hai gọi tiếp tục đây
này khi các macro dùng để làm gì biết
các lỗi
các bạn một số cái ứng dụng cơ bản và
các bạn không cần phải viết cốt vbi mà
các bạn có thể dùng máy tính năng viết
code này các bạn nào ngoài ra thì các
bạn có thể sử dụng caragor này để các
bạn có thể tra xem là các cái tập lệnh
và các bạn không biết dùng trong video
như nào giả sử mình không biết tô màu
thì mình dùng cái lệnh gì hoặc là w thì
mình dùng như thế nào thì mình sẽ dùng
với các makro trước tiếp theo mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn sử dụng với các macro
để mình tại một cái danh sách các mục
lục bây giờ sửa đây mình tạo một cái làm
nên nhắc tới là cái cửa sổ chính nhé
xong ở đây mình sẽ xít là địa tháng 1
chẳng hạn đấy Ở đây là ship tháng 2 đợi
thì trong cái bên này mình sẽ tạo thành
mày xóa đi trong các bên này vì sẽ tạo
hai cái bát được thế còn có thể liên sợ
này các bạn chọn cái gì xếp này mình sẽ
chọn cái hình là ví dụ chọn hình này đi
còn tự chữa cháy bạn kéo nhé hệ thống
các bạn nháy chuột phải vào đây gọi chọn
aristech mình sẽ ghi là tháng 1 của hạn
thế nhá ạ
khi bạn Bôi đen này là thì hôm mình căn
giữa đi Mày bị co lại Ok mình có cái bát
rằm tháng 1 rồi Vui quá thích là các từ
này không Bạn rất cần cho thích ra để
mình có một cái là tháng 2 nhé bởi gọi
Nháy chuột phải con aristech để bị sửa
cái số một thành tháng 2 tức là mình sẽ
tạo hay các bác tầm này để khi mình
thích và các từ này nó sẽ nhảy sang cả
cái tháng tương ứng vào đây là toàn tích
vào đây không Bạn giữ control sinh ở đây
mình và thẻ format đã bị like Các bạn ơi
lightless bỏ ra cũng đều được để bị rất
căn 2 cái này bằng nhau ở Ví dụ mình tạo
này cho nhìn thấy nó đẹp hơn pro hơn nhé
Đây là cái vùng để tạo mục lục bây giờ
mình sẽ thực hiện đi con mắt luôn nhé
các bạn vào thẻ developer này mình xem
bấm đi con macro đấy thì nó sẽ hiện ra
một cái cửa sổ mới ở đây nó yêu cầu mình
đặt tên cho cái macro này Ví dụ mình đặt
tên là gì ạ tháng 1 mọi thứ nhất tên của
cái máy luôn là phải biết liền nhé mình
sẽ đặt tên là tháng 1 tại vì cái
tổ chức thực hiện tiếng Việt là chuyển
đến tháng 1 nhất để tiếp theo là ở phía
dưới này là các bạn muốn tạo cái phím
tắt cho cây mắc đô đấy hoặc là các bạn
có thể mô tả thì ở đây mình không cần
thiết Các bạn bấm ok thì sau khi các bạn
bấm ok thì ở bên này nó sẽ chuyển thành
là stop với các định là nếu mà bạn muốn
dừng lại thì bạn tích vào đây thì nhiên
ở đây nó đang ghi rồi lại có bảo đây
mình thu nhỏ lại thì bạn thứ nhất sau
khi mà các bạn thích record macro với
thì ở bên này nó sẽ tạo cái mô đun mới
để lưu cái macro của mình thì ở đây lúc
đấy là có mỗi một rồi thì nó sẽ tạo nên
12 thì tên chính là tên tháng một mà tên
macro mình đặt vừa nãy thì tương ứng khi
bạn làm bất cứ thao tác nào ở bên B phải
xem này thì ở bên cái vba này nó sẽ
chuyển thành các câu lệnh của ích của JB
hay nhất bây giờ cái mắc đâu này thì
thực hiện các nhiệm vụ là mình chuyển
đến cái sĩ Khánh một tí về quá thích với
tháng 1 đấy thì vẫn thấy thì tương ứng ở
bên này nó sẽ là cả dễ chết trắng 1.6 ex
đấy
khi mình bấm stop nhắc đây cái biểu
tượng này là top với con định điện thoại
bấm dưng như vậy là mình đã xong một cái
mắt đâu này thì cách mắc luôn lại chỉ
làm nhiệm vụ là chuyển đến cái sĩ Thắng
hộ thôi Đấy bây giờ các bạn quay về ca
sĩ bên này đây các bạn nháy chuột phải
vào các bác tuần này nhá trong các bạn
chọn assign macro nãy mình sẽ ráng mà
cái macro tháng 1 này có tích lũy và cái
tháng bộ này nha hoặc các bạn tích vào
tháng 1 các tỉnh ok đấy về Gọi thoát ra
họ thích ra ngoài bây giờ các bạn chỉ
cần kích vào cái tháng 1 này thì nó sẽ
tự động có nhiều những cái shit tháng 1
này để rất là hai tháng 1 đến tháng 1
thì tương tự mình sẽ record in cho cái
macro để khi mình thích vào tháng 2 nó
sẽ nhảy sang tháng 2 đây thì các bạn
cũng thích và cái biểu tượng với con
macro này là mình sẽ đặt tên là tháng
hay ăn thế nhất sẽ gọi Tĩnh ok đấy khi
bạn tạo của các bác được tháng 2 gọi
thấy ở bên này nó sẽ tạo một cái chương
trình mới và tên là D chính là cái tên
lúc đấy ghi là tháng 2 Đâu Bây giờ còn
chỉ cần dịch và cái ship tháng
Ừ để thì tương ứng là cái lại xuýt cả
hai chấm select không thằng nào các bạn
ở nơi này các bạn stock các bạn dừng ghi
luôn để như vậy các bạn đã xong được một
cái chương trình tháng 2 ở đây và nhiệm
vụ của nó là chỉ lựa chọn cái tháng 2
này mấy đoạn Quay lại cửa sổ bên nhá
mình nháy và cái này mình dán vừa sai
macro mình ráng lên cái mắt đầu tháng 2
lúc đấy Đấy Bây giờ thích vào tháng 2
này Đấy nó nhảy theo tháng hay bị tích
vào tháng 10 này là tháng Một đây ví dụ
mình tạo cái bác Tâm để quay về cái cửa
sổ bên nhé Tại Ví dụ mình bạn Insert này
chọn cái hình mũi tên điện ảnh mũi tên
quay về vẫn giữ chuột trái và kéo này
đấy bạn nhớ chụp phải edit technique
mình sẽ viết là diện quay về bên để hạ
thế này lại khi bạn tích vào cây lút này
thì nó sẽ quay về bên này thì ví dụ mình
đang ở tháng 1 chẳng hạn nha các bạn
thủy cho bạn không thể tích và cái xích
bên này đó các bạn có thể ở một trong
axit Tháng 1 và tháng 2 thì ví dụ mình
đang ở chiến thắng một nhé Thì gọi Bảo
thẻ đi
Ê mày có bạn chọn record macro mình sẽ
đạt là gì mình đặt ở bên để hạ thế nào
là mình sẽ đạt được quay về bên quay về
bên các bạn Tĩnh Ok để nó ngay lập tức
nó sẽ tạo một cái chương trình là quay
về bên cái này các bạn chỉ cần tích và
ca sĩ lên đâu cái con mắt luôn này là
như vậy đấy thích nên chấm selects về
bạn dừng ghi tóc Ok Bây giờ các bạn quay
lại cái này nhé các bạn nháy chuột phải
vào đây bác từng này các bạn dán ở sai
macro các bạn dán vào điện quay về bên
đấy về bạn cũng nhớ chụp phải bạn copy
cái bát tượng này sang cái tháng 2 này
Đấy mình ở đây Các bạn hãy gọi Nháy
chuột phải chọn chết luôn vào đây thì
lúc này cái mũi tên này Nó sẽ giúp các
bạn để quay về bên nhắc về các bạn thích
vào đây Đấy gọi theo quay về bên và các
bạn sang thứ hai các bạn thích quay về
bên đã ví dụ mình bạn tháng 1 này để
không mạnh quay về bên tháng 2 này quay
về bên đã rất là hay đây là ứng dụng đơn
giản của
em alo để mình chạm cái danh sách mục
lục rất là danh sách liên kết giữa các
sheet với nhau thì ở cuối chương trình
mình sẽ hướng dẫn thêm cho các bạn
record macro để làm được những cái việc
khá là hữu ích cũng khá là nâng cao của
phần dưới con cá rô đấy tiếp theo mình
sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn cách để dùng hàm
trong vba với Ví dụ mình có một ngày hai
này bố này thì bây giờ các bạn muốn tính
tổng nhé Thì để dùng được hàm tính tổng
thì bạn làm sao về Ví dụ mình thích là
một đôi một mình biết tốt nhất ở đây
mình xóa đi đây các bạn muốn lấy hàm
tổng thì mình sẽ Ví dụ mình khai báo một
cái biến tiệm cận s hoặc là double S
line à Bây giờ mình sẽ ráng là diện mình
sẽ tổng bảng bây giờ bị mình dùng hàm
xăm nhé Thì bạn gõ để gõ được hàm cho
Excel bạn gọi tao này chấm chấm s tăng
sừng này đấy chấm gì chấm làm sao luôn
Xem các bạn mở ngoặc luôn
ở đây ở đây là từ điện đoạn này là ok
đến điểm B 6 nữa thì tích vào đây mở
ngoặc ra là B3 B6 đấy quạt đóng ngoặc
kép dấu ngoặc đơn lại đấy đóng ngoặc đơn
nữa điện xong làm sao nhé Bây giờ mình
có msgbox mình hiện thông báo ra và các
bạn Ấn cardspace này mình đi là tổng mở
ngoặc là tổng dãy số là thì hạn thứ nhất
thằng bạn mới tập nên chọn bấm chạy nhé
đấy Ở đây mình thừa mấy cái dấu ngoặc
đơn này cái thật lớn chạy nhé đấy thì
rất hiện thông báo tầm lễ số là 10 đây
tổng của 1 2 3 4 l = 10 đấy ví dụ ở đây
là 100V còn chạy lại nhé tiếp tổng là
106 Okay Đây là cách để mình dùng hàng
thì các bạn chú ý để dùng hàng nóng
Excel thì mình phải thêm chữ Excel chấm
nước xi măng Sơn Tuy nhiên có một số
hàng thì lại không như thế ví dụ hàng
lép nhé
cho ví dụ các bạn gõ thì em SG vóc là rõ
làm việc mình vẫn là lép luôn nét của
chữ Diệp ví dụ gái Excel này phải ví dụ
mình lấy 2 ký tự chẳng hạn thế nhá thì
nó sẽ trả về chữ gà này tức là cái duyên
với hạt lép chẳng hạn thì lại không dùng
Excel chấm box tăng dần đâu Ở đây bị xóa
cái này đi cả để với toàn chạy này đấy
thì nó sẽ trả về chữ gà thì tương tự Nếu
còn gõ dai này mà lấy năm chẳng hạn thế
Thì nó sẽ trả về chữ Excel đấy Gãy xe
đấy thì đa số các hàng đều dùng lá Excel
cái bộ xi măng rừng để biết cái nào nào
mà không dùng được tính năng đấy thì bạn
chỉ cần gõ cho mình là Excel này chấm
oxit anh xin lại chấm Ví dụ mình nghĩ là
cái hạt lép phải dùng cái này nha các
bạn gọi lép này đấy Con này nó sẽ không
ra thì như vậy Đang nằm nép thì không
cần dùng thuốc thích tăng trưởng nữa mà
các bạn gọi trực tiếp làm nét Thôi lấy
giao hàng
Ừ Thì thực tế thì có rất ít hàm mà còn
gọi trực tiếp còn đa số các hàm thì các
bạn phải dùng Excel thấm gốc xi măng
xinh để các bạn gọi cái hàng mới lên ví
dụ như viện cấp là Excel tướng Quốc sẽ
tăng trưởng chậm Vlookup đấy hoặc là son
Lipice này là thảm cao gì đấy đều phải
như thế chỉ có một số hành khách những
hàm lép like hoặc làm len thì không cần
Ví dụ ở đây Hà Lan để hạn chế nhất xin
cái độ dài của các ký tự lái xe thì hạ
thế thì nó sẽ ra là mấy gà là hay Excel
là năm cộng nhiều cách diễn ra là táo
nhé nếu bạn thấy để nó hiện số 8 Ok Bây
giờ là cái phần hay nhất trong cái bài
hôm nay là mình sẽ làm cho các bạn khá
nhiều ví dụ để các bạn có thể hiểu hơn
về cách dùng các khái niệm cơ bản của
Ivy cũng như có thể ứng dụng được vào
chương trình của bạn cách sử dụng
Advanced filter Triều Tiên các bạn mở
cửa sổ ghi rồi mới thích ra các bạn Bống
r11 Sau đó bạn sẽ nháy chuột phải một
cái xin bất kỳ các
em khỏi chọn môđun để mình biết cô điện
thì đầu tiên các bạn sẽ dùng hiện sắp
này Ví dụ mình đặt tên chương trình nhận
diện lọc nâng cao có đóng mở ngoặc
Center đầu tiên các bạn sẽ khai báo biến
nhất các bạn khai báo cho mình một cái
gim Rain and Rain chạy thì cái với này
chính là cái vùng dữ liệu của mình nhé
các bạn sẽ đặt luôn xem nên sẽ bằng điện
bằng ship còn mở ngon nhé Ở đây tiên
chính là data nó các bạn mở ngoặc data
chấm Diện chấm lên đầu tiên mình rất
chọn cái cột đầu tiên của Vi vùng dữ
liệu ở đây là bê bối nạn thì đoạn mở
ngoặc ra là B4 em các bạn đóng ngoặc kép
đóng ngoặc đơn lại các bạn chấm color as
is dead tức là gì B4 ở đây này trong các
bạn chấm Courage is thì nó sẽ bôi tất cả
các vùng dữ liệu ở đây các bạn tiếp theo
thì mình phải
3 cách biến và mình sẽ đặt cái vùng là
vùng điều kiện tại thì bạn cũng khai báo
thêm một cái biến Dream Việt clear
stereo stereo Rain hãy cũng Aspirin tại
sau đó các loại xe ga thì các bạn cũng
xét gọi bộ đèn còn copy nhận ngày trước
phải các bạn copy lại các bạn nhớ nhập
vai của bạn bết vào đây cho mình thì cái
này của mình sẽ là diện clip các bạn ấn
cardspace nhé chấm dứt ở đây cái điều
kiện thì mình sẽ Bôi đen từ cái ô j42
các bạn là j4 tiếp theo thì mình sẽ đặt
cái vùng để mình chiết xuất nha gì mình
copy Rain Tức là mình copy đấy cùng
Aspirin thì mình cũng đặt nhá các bạn
cần chuẩn bị ở đây này thì ở đây mình sẽ
biến là dịp các bạn ạ copy gọn cardspace
nhé lại Ví dụ mình chiết xuất dữ liệu ra
cái cột N4 này chẳng hạn tiếng Anh
về giá lại N4 bị xóa records thì cứ rất
là đơn giản ra cái rgd 9:00 vùng dữ liệu
của mình đúng hạn các bạn as lag chấm
enter tấn pháp này cách ra này đầu tiên
Excel là gì Các bạn là XL filter Copy
lại Tấn tác phẩm biến thứ hai là
crystalline chính là cái Cristian lên ở
đây của mình Glico Tấn cardspace nhá lại
phải cái copy lên đây chính là copy gạch
rẻ của mình có ấn Cân trên sân bay và
các bạn gõ này copy lên nữa đây Okay bây
giờ có bạn chạy đơn giản với mình thích
chạy Nga đấy còn thấy không như vậy nó
sẽ chiết xuất ra được là hai người họ
Nguyễn bây giờ giả sử mình không muốn họ
Nguyễn mình muốn là kệ bắt đầu là tên là
chữ L chẳng hạn thì họ lại bắt đầu bằng
chữ L có ăn thích l vào đây các bạn quay
trở lại chương trình nhất ở đây mình
phải
- chọn xít này còn can c copy chien.vn
tắt mở ngoặc ra từ cái cột n đến cột dữ
liệu của mình là từ 1l đến cột p chẳng
hạn nhất gen của mở ngoặc n là 2T tại
đóng ngoặc chấm chấm ít này đầu tiên này
mình chạy cái lệnh này trước nha các bạn
ấn ra ở đây này anh còn xét về dưới này
đấy thì nó sẽ xóa đi tôi là nó xóa các
dữ liệu mình lọc trên đấy đi nhé để mình
tạo máy lọc mới mà lại bản chất cái lệnh
Delete là như vậy ok đấy gọi thế chứ nó
sẽ Lọc ra tất cả những cái người và họ
bắt đầu bằng chữ Ly ở đây về giả sử mình
muốn học thêm là những cái người mà mà
họ mà còn chữ lờ nha Nhưng mà điều kiện
là tổng điểm và lớn năm các bạn copy đây
các bạn tết tổng điểm ở đây có bạn
ở đây thì nó sẽ lọc thỏa mãn hai điều
kiện để họ bắt đầu bằng chữ L và tổng
điểm lớn năm còn quay trở lại chương
trình Các bạn bấm chạy Nga đấy chạy như
vậy Ở đây lúc này Chỉ còn lại từ lấy bạn
đang tổng điểm đều lớn hơn 5 Ví dụ đặc
điểm lớn hơn bạn ấy nhé xem là có bao
nhiêu bạn lúc này Chỉ còn bao nhiêu lần
một hai bạn thôi còn chạy nha Bây giờ
mình vẫn ngoan lên đấy như vậy chỉ còn
hai bạn thôi ngoài họ lời để nhận ra thì
mình muốn họ bắt đầu bằng chữ p nữa đi
Chẳng hạn bên thì những cái bạn B và
tổng biển vị nhỏ hơn nữa để mình tin với
mà họ bắt đầu bằng chữ L thì tổng điểm
lớn 7 và nếu vẫn đầu bằng b thì nhỏ nằm
tại bây giờ mình lại chạy Gọi Loan đã
nhận họ bắt đầu bằng chữ p thì có mấy
Phạm đây Phạm đây lớn năm bây giờ xử
mình bắt đầu bằng chữ H đi Chẳng hạn nhá
cả bằng chữ t chữ t có vẻ nhiều hơn bên
còn chạy lại chương trình Nha ơi mình là
nước mắt từng mình cho nó dễ các bạn vào
nhưng sợ này hoặc là mình
Ai biểu tượng này cho dễ để mình gắn mác
luôn ạ lại còn giữ trái bọn kéo nhé Tại
vì mình ghi là gì để RS Exciter điện
hoặc là mình lọc nâng cao mình gọi là SV
kiếm tự Ok kính lúp này bạn Bôi đen các
bạn căng giữa và hôm mình cũng căn giữa
luôn Ok nháy chuột phải vào cái hình này
các bạn ơi sai macro thêm cái tên của
chương trình mềm đặt là lọc nâng cao lại
còn tính nước vào đây để về các bạn chỉ
cần chạy ạ Bây giờ họ T và tổng điểm lớn
Nam điện thế bạn event Vinpearl đấy như
vậy là họ bắt đầu bằng t đều có tổng
điểm lớn năm đơn dao động đến mình đọc
nhỏ nằm là không có ví dụ tên nhưng mà T
lại nhỏ hơn 7 đi nhé đại T và họ đã
nhiều hơn 7 ảnh Tổng điểm mà ngoãn 7 nha
con Evan winter
em như vậy là gì ở đây ví dụ Họ bắt đầu
bằng chữ L thì có hai bạn là có tổng
điểm lớn hơn 7 này và T thì có một bạn
là nhỏ hơn 7 rồi Ok rất là hay được
trước này ví dụ là gì ạ Ví dụ ở đây bị
nhận một nhé nhân lấy một chiếc bảng
điện nhanh còn hai chấm và Môi trường hạ
thế tương tự ở đây sẽ là diện một ngân
hay ở đây là một X2 = 2A biết dựa Đây là
hai lại chọn nhân 12 chấm bằng hai tương
tự như vậy thì mình sẽ làm ở đây cho các
bạn xem nha đi làm kiểu chưa ký hiệu đây
là ship bốn thì nó vẫn là thứ Hai nhé
các bạn chỉ các bạn làm như sau Ví dụng
gì là gì mình ghi chú đi tin
ô kính sương ra màn hình nhưng mà chưa
thì các bạn chúng em mình lúc này mình
sử dụng hai đứa một biến số chạy theo cổ
tức là từ 1x 2x 3x 4 và một cái biến
chạy theo hàng ở đây gọi giống hai biến
nhất định ví dụ biến là biến y thể chạy
từ 1 đến 9 ở đây biến này là biến di sẽ
chặn cụm từ 1 đến 9 ở bên này mình sẽ
nào hay biết gì easy and interior các
bạn chữ hai vòng lặp for y = 1 q9f một
các bạn hết luôn để bạn đỡ Quyên là cấu
trúc của cái vòng khoa đầu tiên đạt chủ
nghĩa Phòng kho đầu tiên sẽ chạy đây ạ
chạy theo cổ đây vòng soi thứ hai là kho
di là một q9f một nét luôn à
ở mình thường ấy mình sẽ biết là gì mình
sẽ biết sau một cái cú pháp của một cựu
vòng ngọc luôn để tránh bị thiếu các bạn
đánh tát nhé sau đây các bạn sẽ gán
chương trình các bạn sự hiện diện
Facebook là sấm sét trích đoạn có thể gõ
tên là ship bốn hoặc các bạn ship này nó
nằm ở thi thứ hai bạn có thể là số 2
theo cũng được ạ để chấm điện chấm sao
Ai Cập 1 để phải thì cũng phải là Duy
cộng một quán gà rán bằng miệng bằng đầu
tiên nhé ví dụ y = 1 và g bằng 1 thì
đoạn thẳng D là diện I là các bạn và
cách ra này vận cách này dấu nhân này
bạn và đi này già này già đẹp có ghi là
hai chấm bằng thấy nó gọi về đi
cá nhân dị này mình sẽ giải thích các
loại theo các bạn mở rộng ra một tí gọi
làm cái này đây mình chặn trước nhé mình
sẽ trước để các bạn xem nó ra kết quả
như nào lấy gọi thấy rất là nhanh sẽ ra
bạn từ trước đầu tiên nó sẽ chạy là diện
Y sẽ chạy đầu tiên là xe bằng 1 đúng thì
gì sẽ chạy từ 1 đến 9 ở đây Còn nếu như
mà mình ở đây mình không có cậu một nhé
các bạn chú ý nếu không có cộng một ở
đây để bị xóa cái này đi xóa đi mình
chạy lại nhé Nếu nhưng không có cậu một
đấy thì nó sẽ chạy từ biểu đầu tiên này
ạ để nó sẽ không chạy thì đâu này nữa mà
nó sẽ chạy qua một đầy Các bạn thấy đấy
sẽ chạy từ 31 đây Còn nếu như mình cộng
một ở đây cộng một ở đây thì nó sẽ lùi
xuống một hành và một cột lúc đấy dữ
liệu nó sẽ chạy từ vob2 này ở đây ạ tại
của mình sẽ ra ở đây à
Ừ thế thì có danh sách các thí sinh thi
đại học đầu tiên là số báo danh tên ngày
sinh địa chỉ nên là các môn điểm ưu tiên
tổng điểm và kết quả bên này là mẫu in
để gửi kết quả cho các thí sinh Đây là
số báo danh để tên thí sinh ngày sinh
địa chỉ đây là điểm thi và kết quả ở đây
Đây là ghi chú ạ đầu tiên chương trình
của mình sẽ là quét theo số báo danh từ
số báo danh đầu tiên đến số danh cuối
cùng suy nghĩ sẽ điền vào đây sau đó thì
bên thí sinh ngày sinh địa chỉ và các hệ
thống kinh khác sẽ là Villa cấp từ số
báo danh thì ở đây cái Tab lễ chúng ta
sẽ làm như sau bằng với lúc cấp lại các
bạn tìm theo số báo danh này phải là thứ
hai là bảng giá trị rò thì các bạn mô
đen tất cả cái bảng này cho mình nha
phẩy cụ trả về Ví dụ mình đang là tên
của trả về là cuộc số 2 phẩy ở đây mình
tìm chính xác là không
cho ví dụ cái số báo danh nhé ví dụ mình
của gió thành lập quỹ ha001g hạn nhé
mình cái điền số có thành q201 rồi đi
bạn theo tên nó sẽ nhảy theo cái phần
ngày suy nghĩ thì động công thức cũng
giống như là đoạn các bạn copy bạn cần
chuẩn bị thì bạn tay cậu trả về là số 2
theo rằng thứ ba ngày sinh thì mình đổi
thành để định dạng ngày tháng đấy bạn
nhấn chuột phải bạn vào format Cell Tại
mình sao bạn biết địa chỉ thì cũng tương
tự nha các bạn đang trên V lại các bạn
địa chỉ là số 4 câu trả về của số 4 hãy
điện toán thì cụ trả về sẽ là cuộc số
nam điểm lý là của trẻ là Quân số 6 để
định hóa của trẻ đã có số bệnh ưu tiên
là cuộc trả về số 8 Tổng điểm
em về số 9 có các bạn tổng điểm các bạn
có thể bằng xăm ở đây cũng được luôn ạ
Kết quả thì là cột chữ 10 của trẻ về thứ
10 đấy Ok khi ta tạo xong cái này thì ta
xét một cái là Queen Alia để khi mà mình
pin ra thì nó sẽ chỉ những thông tin này
ra các bạn tích vào thẻ visa và các bạn
vào xếp vinareal đoạn tích và xếp này
Vinamilk đây đấy thì khi in thì nó chỉ
in cái vùng lựa chọn này thôi ok Mỹ Giải
thích cái chương trình chương trình của
mình đầu tiên sẽ lật quét số báo danh
đầu tiên này xong là số thứ Hai thứ Ba
đến số danh cuối cùng sẽ điền vào đây
thì các thông tin liên quan đến đây nó
sẽ tự nhảy theo các bạn được đây là hàm
thông Ví dụ ở đây mà khi mà nhảy ra số
báo danh quý ha02 thì vậy là không tất
cả các công ty ở dưới này cũng nhảy theo
tên là Nguyễn Văn hay là ok Bây giờ mình
sẽ biết cốt nhé các bạn có thể
A11 nhá và các bạn vào trẻ đi lớp ơn các
bạn và bây giờ mới thích ở đây mình ấn
Anh lớp 11 đầu tiên các bạn sẽ tạo một
cái mô đun để các bạn viết quốc nha hãy
gọi thích nút và môđun để viết cốt triệu
nhỉ biết là tên chương trình sản Xác để
trên chương trình diễn nhảy kết quả thi
trung học phổ thông và hạ thế các bạn
đóng mở ngoặc kép enter đầu tiên mình sẽ
khai báo một biến biến y gì interior
Biến I này sẽ làm gì Các bạn chú ý nhé
Cái biến y này mục đích là nó sẽ chạy từ
cây số báo danh đầu tiên đến số các
thanh cuối cùng nhé này thì đầu tiên
mình sẽ ráng là gì y = 2x y = 2 là chính
là cây hàng thứ hai là thí sinh đầu tiên
sau đó mình sẽ dùng một vòng là Mũ hay
nhất của bạn ngoài là bạn trên Facebook
các loại ấn cardspace nhé
Anh ơi sếp sin dữ liệu để là nằm ở đầu
tiên là xin số 1 để có anh sống một thôi
chấm Sao của y phẩy một mạng khác rỗng
khác rỗng đóng ngoặc lại cái có ai là
thực ra thì có thể không cần đóng mở
ngoặc đơn con có thể cắt cái này cũng
được à Đấy tức là gì nó sẽ quét từ đầu
đến cuối khi nào mà khác giống thì dừng
tức nào đấy đến cái thằng cu ta không
mười này thì nó sẽ dừng nhé Thì để làm
về các bạn phải dán lại y = y + 1 trong
các bạn quen để ba cái câu lệnh này là
bắt buộc phải có tại vì sao ạ thấy ghen
à để kết thúc cái vòng lặp while này cú
pháp và nó như vậy cái y = y cấp ổn định
tức là sau khi mà làm xong cái thí sinh
đầu tiên thì mình tăng lên 1 Để mình làm
với thí sinh thứ 2 có ảnh hưởng ạ thì
mình có thể coi nhỏ lại gọn dễ nhìn nha
à
vì vậy Cái này nó nằm ở trong cái vòng
lại bạn có thể ấn cả phải nó thu vào đâu
nhé Để cho nên thơ đầu tiên mình đi chú
chương trình nhé Mình ghi là diện In
danh sách kết quả thi trung học phổ
thông ví dụ y = 2 có thể ghi chú là gì
quét từ thí sinh đầu tiên này thí sinh
đầu tiên có một đoạn dây hiểu lại quét
thí sinh tiếp theo là thí sinh tiếp theo
thì đầu tiên các bạn phải dán nhá các
bạn chú ý nhất các bạn bè gán là cái xe
ở đây này các vị trí này chính là cái xe
của hàng thứ 4 mà cột D là có bốn tức là
xe của 44 gọi xe gắn bằng số báo danh
nhé Thì đoạn bằng gạo rít Facebook các
bạn ấn cân
hình ảnh 8 chấm axit này cạnh thứ nhất
ít mẫu in là cái xếp thứ hai ai còn chấm
Sao của rẻ 44,4 phẩy bố này tức là cái
vị trí này họ sẽ gán cho bằng viện bằng
gia FaceBook các bạn nhấn cardspace pháp
này chấm hiện sheet1 này sheet 1.co xe
của địa các bạn chú ý nhất chấm xe của
số báo danh là sale của y mà y đang chạy
nhưng mà cầu thủ luôn luôn là cột 1 thì
các bạn cuoi1 y phẩy một cái khi mãi
tăng lên một đứa thì là sale của 3,1
thôi là thí sinh thứ 2 tăng lên một rõ
là thí sinh thứ 3 với mình chất thì các
bạn xem nhé các bạn chỉ cần chạy khách
hàng này với nhau với mình test thử nhé
à
vì thế các bạn ấn gian này thì đầu tiên
là y = 2 đúng không nó sẽ chạy này Đầu
tiên nó sẽ gán là cái số báo danh sẽ là
bằng bằng xe của 21 Tức là số phận anh
của và Q1 đã có 60 có chạy nó xem được
dán đầu tiên là vì y = 1 chứng xơ gan là
quyết a001 này đây qh300 một thí sinh
đầu tiên sau đó lấy tăng y lên là một
thì lại quét cái thí sinh a cộng hai nó
xơ gan và với oxy 44 là bạn nhìn nhận và
em cái bước này nó sẽ ga này bạn nhìn
cái này nó sẽ tăng lên này kia không hay
ạ đấy quen không ai thì tất cả các thông
tin này sẽ nhảy theo vì ở đây là mình
hành với lúc được đấy thí sinh này làm
đang bị chưa đây tiếp theo lại tăng lên
có thể gọi này rồi Ok mình stop em Đỡ
bớt lại nha như vậy là mình đã xong bước
là bước duyệt các cái thí sinh rồi Bây
giờ làm sao để yên nhé còn chửi nhé câu
lệnh in ấn làm hay sao ạ Các bạn vẫn cứ
giữ Facebook là chấm xít mình đang in
cái xít hay mà xinh hay này sớm quá ghi
lập Vina print out ở đây mình preview
này bằng phô Tức là mình không preview
đã cái câu lệnh này là câu lệnh in à vì
ở đây Các bạn chú ý nghe cái máy mình
không có máy in thì các bạn ấn cao trên
PC này thì cáp internet chính là kế máy
in mặc định của bạn thẻ đây mình im là
im pdf Thôi thì nếu mà có máy in được
thì nó tự in được nó sẽ không hỏi nữa ỉa
đây là in pdf thì nó sẽ hỏi khi mình bởi
vì đi thì nó bắt mình phải đặt tên đấy
Lại còn hiểu yếu còn nếu bạn bạn in rồi
in ra giấy thì nó sẽ không hỏi
em để cái câu lệnh này là cái câu lệnh
để in in ra máy in ạ bây giờ bao giờ
mình chạy nhé về mình nhận ra này Đấy
đầu tiên này Các này nó sẽ in cái thí
sinh 001 này ở đây nó bắt mình phải là
đặt tên đấy ví dụ mình đi mà quỹ ha001
trả mình như ra destop nhé Không lại bắt
đầu in cái thí sinh tiếp theo đấy nhảy
Đăng ký sinh không hay ngắn thì mình lại
đặt được USA 002 hạ thế này Đấy nó sẽ in
đến các thí sinh cuối cùng làm sao mình
cho tốt đây lúc đấy là mình có được hai
thí sinh này bạn mở lên nha Để con thấy
không psa-01 Đây để thí sinh một tương
tự qe-02 điện lại thí sinh số 2 như vậy
với những cái câu lệnh rất đơn giản như
ngày qua các bạn có thể làm được một
việc rất là
Ừ nếu mà làm tay Ví dụ mà một trường mà
có hàng trăm nghìn thí sinh thì các bạn
không thể trên tay được mở cái này rất
là tiện bây giờ mình chất tạo một cái
nút báo tường ở đây nhé Còn kính lúp đây
tạo với bác Tâm ở đây để mình diện tích
thôi lại các bạn vào vẫn đi với rapper
này các bạn vào Yên sạc thì mình sẽ
thích và các bác thường đây mình kéo yêu
mình là mình sẽ gắn vào cái kết quả thi
mà cái mắc luôn mình vừa biết các bạn
bấm Đăng ai ở đây mình có thể là vượt
nút này mình đổi tên nhé đổi tên là i
này danh sách Ok thì các bạn khi các bạn
bấm biệt danh sách thôi thì nó sẽ chạy
chương trình này là ví dụ mình đầu tiên
mình sẽ đạt là quy ra không một này tiếp
theo thí sinh thứ 2 thì mình đặt là quê
ra không hay tất là vì mình yêu w nên nó
mới hỏi còn các bạn với in giấy thì nó
sẽ không hỏi đâu Họ chỉ như vậy nhé
nhưng mà trong trường hợp
em không muốn đi hết danh sách mà mình
sẽ in từ danh sách thứ hai đến danh sách
thứ ba là rất là yên một số lượng khách
nhất định không Ví dụ có một trăm nghìn
thí sinh Như mình chỉ muốn in độ khoảng
10 thí sinh đầu tiên thôi thì hoặc là
người đi sinh từ vi sinh thứ hai mươi
chẳng hạn Chỉ đấy các bạn không thể dùng
làm quay được nha Thì bạn thể dùng vòng
For để ví dụ mình đóng đi hàng quay lại
lại đi các bạn chỉ cần đánh dấu phẩy
thôi thì coi như là cái này nó thành ghi
chú được thì mình có thể là pho là y
vàng ví dụ minh in từ thí sinh thứ 10
nhé tù 20 hạ lại step 1 chẳng hạn nhé
Tức là mình sẽ chỉ in từ thí sinh thứ 10
đến thứ 20 đó ở đây Mình bỏ cái gặp một
đây cho mình bấm AK để như vậy là ở đây
mình sẽ in là từ thí sinh chữ người đến
trước xe 20 thôi hiện tại đây mình có 10
test để ví dụ từ thứ 3 đến thứ năm Tức
là mình in 3 bạn là bạn thứ ba thứ tư
thứ năm không thì mình có thể dùng làm
cho này trong trường
14 inch toàn bộ danh sách thì bạn có thể
dùng làm for này để in một số danh sách
nhất định phải cho việc các bạn muốn in
tất cả khi bạn phải để lại vòng lặp
while và ND cho mình đầu tiên ta xem vào
thẻ developer các bạn tích và ghi rồi
music hoặc các bạn ấn phím tắt An F11
Sau đó các bạn nhảy chuột phải các bạn
và Insert môđun mình sẽ tạo mô đun để
viết cấu lại ở đây mình thu nhỏ cửa sổ
lại cho dễ nhìn nha ví dụ ở đây mình có
ba xít nhé mình xin giải thích qua về
chương trình như sau thì đầu tiên mình
sẽ khai và một cái biến và đột biến Ngốc
Xít thì nó sẽ quét lần lượt các sheet
trong cái file này Ví dụ ở đây có axit
thì nó sẽ quyết lần lượt Z1 Z2 Z3 và nó
sẽ kiểm tra tương xít Một có phải là
chất kích thích hay không Còn nếu mà ca
sĩ mà không phải là sẽ tiếp từ là ca sĩ
nằm ở đây này không phải là ship 1 chẳng
hạn thì nó sẽ xóa đi để thử toán rất
Ừ vậy thôi thì đầu tiên các bạn thích
nước và môđun nhé Để mình viết code ghi
chú đây ví dụ mình ghi là chương trình
Xóa các sheet khác hạ không phải là Siri
tiếp đấy thì gọi thứ nhất cấu trúc của
một chương trình với đặc sắc sau đây tên
chương trình ví dụ mình đi đã xóa để xóa
xuýt điện các bạn đóng mở ngoặc đơn nhé
enter sau đó ta xếp khai báo một biến
các loại ghim này mình sẽ khai báo một
biến đã biến góc xít điện s diện oxit
các bạn ứng cardspace nhất thì nó sẽ gợi
nhắc cho các bạn mình đi lấy bô xít này
ấm áp như vậy là mình đã có một cái biến
bác sĩ rồi thì cái biến này sẽ làm việc
diện nó sẽ quét lần lượt 3 sĩ ở đây Đấy
Và nó sẽ kiểm tra xem là từng sheet 1 có
phải là chia tiếp không Nếu mà không
phải nó sẽ xóa nhé Thì mình sẽ khai báo
một vòng lặp for để mình Quét tất cả các
xe Ford này
It is Xbox it in this các bạn ấn tiếp
kespa nhất facebook.in chấm xít vào oxit
cũng được Đây là mình Sấm Sét đi thằng
các bạn nick để kết thúc thì làm sao này
như vậy là cái vòng là pho này sẽ giải
quyết các việc Việt cây cuốc sĩ này nó
sẽ quét lần lượt 3 ca sĩ này thì mình sẽ
ghi lại ít này nếu ước xít chấm nêm mà
khác với Facebook là chấm hết các bạn
ghi lại Cắt xít nhé anh tiếp ship nghĩa
là gì Nghĩa là cái sim mà mình đang lựa
chọn mình đang thao tác này đấy chấm nên
Zen bạn có nhà hàng eresson nhận thì
mình kết thúc Hãy viết lại sau đó mình
lên trên mình viết câu lệnh trong cái
hàm ít mà ăn ít này rất là nếu mà khác
thì mình sẽ làm cái cái gì mình đi được
Quốc xít này chấm bi Mat đã còn rất là
đơn giản không Bây giờ mình
số liên kết chương trình khi bạn tích và
rìa bên trái là nó hiện những dấu chấm
đây này lại cho mình chạy nha mình bấm
với cút hình tam giác màu xanh này đấy
thì đầu tiên nó sẽ quét này Đấy x còn gì
không cái cuốc xít đầu tiên đi nó sẽ trả
về là ship một này để Washi chấm lên bạn
thấy không khi mình chả và Quốc chấm đêm
nó sẽ hiện ở dưới là ship một thì nó sẽ
kiểm tra xem là cùng tên với gãy tiếp
ship chấm nêm không thì bạn chú ý nháy
tiếp xít ở đây mình đang là sim một cho
nên đầu tiên nó sẽ là bằng nhau đoạn thì
nó sẽ không làm với việc xóa này lại các
bạn chạy đấy nó kiểm tra tức là hai cái
này là bằng nhau Tôi sẽ nhận xuống em ít
luôn để các bạn quay lại bằng for tiếp
theo thì đến cái sĩ thứ hai của anh thấy
em các bạn chẳng ở đây này nó sẽ hiện
cái là sheet 2 thì nó sẽ kiểm tra à cái
chết hay này nó khác với cả cái A tiết
sheet thì nó sẽ thực hiện các bước này
bước vàng là nó chuẩn bị thực hiện ạ Các
bạn ra một cái đấy Bắt đầu xe nó sẽ hỏi
là cơ bản có thực sự là muốn xóa không
nhất
xe Mỹ Đình đấy bạn theo ở đây nó đánh
mất ít hai được đó lại quét tiếp thì đến
với xích ba thì nó lại Xóa tiếp nó lại
hỏi cái con Thế ông đã mất cái xích bang
này rồi như vậy việc của mình bây giờ
mình mình rất nhiều ship mình không thể
mỗi lần cứ thích giết để bị xóa cái xíu
ở đây được thì mình làm như sau nhé đây
ví dụ mình thêm bài suýt nữa đi để mình
test chương trình thì mình muốn mất cái
hiện thông báo là có sói không ở đây
hiện thì mình làm như sau nhé các bạn đi
là application này các bạn ấn caspi nhé
chấm Display Plus đại bằng phone rất là
gì Tức là nó sẽ không hiện cái thông báo
đấy lên và khi mà sẽ hết là pho lại đổi
chỗ nào khi mà xóa hết bác sĩ rồi thì
mình lại trả về cái hiện thông báo đấy ạ
để tập vacation chấm bi playplus bằng
chu nếu mà các bạn không có câu lệnh này
thì các cái là đi xe lần sau nó sẽ không
hỏi cái đấy đâu cũng rất là nguy hiểm
cho cái người sử dụng lần sau nhé đại
anh sẽ tự giác đây giả sử mình đã có là
hiện có 3 xít Rồi ví dụ bên mình thích
và Z4 đi ship bốn là sẽ Active thì nó sẽ
xóa xếp một người chức năng nó sẽ không
hỏi cửa sổ là có xoáy không đâu đây mình
kiểm tra nhé các bạn thích chủ đề chạy
đấy Em đã xóa xin 1 về sinh năm này nó
không còn cái thông báo này nữa tại bên
mình test lại nhé Bây giờ giả sử cái gì
đáng tiếc là chị chết mày đi Chẳng hạn
nhé về mình bỏ mình đánh cái dấu nháy
đơn ở đây là chuẩn Ghi chú để lại thì
mình ra nhận đơn lấy ghi chú Nếu mà bạn
xóa hai cái này nhá thì nó sẽ hiện thông
báo là mình có mỗi xoáy không lại cùng
test lại cho bạn Nga đấy bọn em nó sẽ
hỏi là mình muốn sói không như vậy cái
việc là mình ghi application chấm bi
Player Plus đây này Nó để bỏ cái thông
báo này đi cho các bạn nhé xin số đi này
với các bạn vẫn chạy đây thấy nó sẽ xóa
Thép 4 và Thiết kia đi Nó chỉ còn lại
trị bệnh thôi Bây giờ việc tiếp theo của
mình mình chạm với bắt thêm ở đây nhé
các bạn tìm các bạn Các bạn có muốn tạo
được không
Anh về chương trình Mình hướng dẫn cho
bạn nào cần tạo thì các bạn vào thẻ
developer là Insulin tại một cái bạn từ
mở ra lại còn giữ chuột trái và kéo đây
này nó sẽ hỏi mình có muốn gán vào cái
mát luôn được công việc bạn tích vào già
Nước Mắt Cô suýt để sở thích chính là
cái tên chương trình mình nạp điện lại
Bây giờ mình đổi tên này nhé bạn điểm
Liên này các bạn Đổi tên đại diện Xóa
các sheet khác thì ok Bây giờ mình chỉ
gần đây bị Tết nên mình tạo thêm hai sim
nữa mình quay lại S7 đây đây thì mình
thích cái xóa xít này thì nó sẽ xóa luôn
xếp các vị trí các bạn Ok bây giờ sử ta
có một cái khay trắng ở đây đầu tiên là
các bạn lưu file nhé Mình sẽ lưu file ở
đây ví dụ mình đi laptop đi Ví dụ là
copy hay từ một thư mục tới
Em hãy cho bạn chọn cái định dạng là mắc
luôn nhé mình bấm xếp Ok thì đầu tiên
mình phải chọn cái đường dẫn thư mục các
bạn Thu nhỏ lại nhá Đấy thì đầu tiên
mình phải copy đấy đường dẫn của thư mục
gốc thì các bạn hỏi lên các bạn vào đây
lại để được phải bạn copy thư mục gốc
thì các bạn nháy vào đây các bạn thân
trên V Các bạn nhớ là thêm một cái dấu
xưởng anh ở đây với nhé đấy tiếp theo
các bạn mở thư mục đích lên không các
bạn tích vào đây các bạn copy đường dẫn
nha Copy lại đoạn thanh chuẩn bị rồi đấy
bạn thêm với sự nhanh đây nó là định
nghĩa của cô đời ví dụ ở đây mình copy
tất cả các loại pha để hạt nha mình vì
sao chấm Sao lại Ok Bước tiếp theo là
các bạn mở cửa sổ lập trình nên các bạn
vào thẻ developer lại các bạn chọn gì ạ
Bây giờ mới thích học các bạn ấn phím
tắt là 211 Nha và Inter các bạn viết
trong môđun nha à
chi tiết chương trình là Thiện Pháp là
korpi free fire tại các bạn đóng mở
ngoặc vào Enter đầu tiên mình sẽ ghi chú
chương trình nhé trường chỉnh có các
file từ một thư mục này tới thư mục khác
hạn ở các đóng cái này để đặt đầu tiên
là các bạn khai báo biến nhất mình sẽ
khai báo biến riêng này SS lại cái này
là cây biến office để mình có thể copy
file tiếp theo là mình sẽ khai quá một
cái biến là sim là kiểu pha nhé kiểu
file thì mới đi được Kiểu file hạ thế
hiểu file sinh cách chuyển file ở đây
chính là cái loại file mà mình sẽ copy
lên ví dụ chấm XL hoặc là chấm đốc hoặc
đây là xanh xanh là tất cả các loại file
đều được nha Tiếp theo mình sẽ khai báo
một biến là rim rim là đường dẫn nhất
Có khi là đường dẫn đường dẫn đường dẫn
thư mục nguồn SJC tiếp theo mình thay
vào thêm một cái biến là đường dẫn thư
mục đích nhé mình đã tên biến hơi dài để
các bạn dễ nhớ thôi SC ngỉ Ok như vậy
mình nhận xong cái tuần thấy nó biến
nhất cái kiểu phải đây chính là cái xa
chấm sao đây này còn cái đình với thể
thu nhỏ lại đầu tiên mình sẽ gán Này bạn
ghi là dẹt đường dẫn lại gọi contour
Super nhé đường dẫn thư mục đích các bạn
sẽ bằng gì Các bạn sẽ gắn luôn bằng Cái
ô này bạn hiểu ạ Được viện Thủ Đức sẽ
bàn giấy Facebook là chấm ít một xin một
mảnh chấm Sao bạn chửi nhất là ở hàng
thứ 3 và cột C tức là đeo 33 đấy ạ
U13 tiếp theo các bạn sẽ giá điện đường
dẫn loạn Tấn connspeeds đường dẫn thư
mục nguồn là cái thư mục đích ở đây là
63 riêng phải là 33 đây là 63 con đường
dẫn thư mục nguồn trong bà mẹ rước là
chấm dứt một chấm theo của niệm 3,3
triệu file các bạn kendra-spade
nhấtnhững kiểu pha giấm bằng gì biết
Facebook là sấm sét một này chấm theo
diện xe của hàng thứ 8 này cột 3 này Ok
như vậy mình đã dán xong thì mình sẽ gắn
Song Thư mục nguồn và thư mục đích và
cái kiểu file rồi đầu tiên các bạn sẽ
đặt cái kiểu biến f-meso này là đối
tượng để mình thao tác với file nha các
bạn test này FeSO4
I created Office chấm chấm chấm
filesystemobject file system of the act
of thúi Đây chỉ là cú pháp là các bạn
Nhớ là được nhé tiếp theo là các bạn sẽ
kiểm tra xem là cái thư mục cần copy với
thư mục đích có tồn tại không nhé ví dụ
các bạn mà đánh nhầm vào đây thì nó sẽ
bảo ra là không tồn tại đến thư mục đấy
thì bạn làm vì sao con ít này nếu như
Diện FS Oh là chấm folder axit axit các
là gì Các bạn Tớ chọn là cái đường dẫn
thư mục đích và thư mục nguồn nhé đường
dẫn các bạn Tấn caspase đường dẫn thư
mục đích này có đóng ngoặc đơn lại mà
bằng phô để Tức là nó không tồn tại cái
thư mục này thì các bạn Zen các bạn sẽ
thì các bạn thể hiện của thông báo là
Mask là ví dụ là có gì là không tồn tại
thư mục đích các bạn enter mình sẽ ghi
là thì axit xác Tức là mình dẫn phát
chương trình luôn và cuối cùng là Pond's
tương tự như vậy mình sẽ kiểm tra cái
đường dẫn thư mục nguồn nha ít là FS ko
chấm điểm folder folder này axit các mở
ngoặc mặt đường dẫn gọn conscience lại
đường dẫn thư mục nguồn bằng phô Zen Zen
thì các bạn cũng hiện thông báo làm axit
bóc lại ra diện không tồn tại thư mục
nguồn lại thông minh Thoát khỏi chương
trình luôn axit tác mình kết thúc với
hàm ít này em ít ít
ở đoạn Lưu vào chắc nhận tiếp theo là
nếu mà hai cái này cũng xảy ra rất là
tồn tại thư mục nguồn thu Mục đích các
bạn sẽ ghi câu lệnh có wifi có bạn dùng
điện FS Oh copy file cách ra thì đầu
tiên là sọt này các bạn hai chấm bằng
cho chính là gì chính là cái đường dẫn
thư mục nguồn các bạn ghi là đường dẫn
con Tấn cardspace nó sẽ nhắc lại xong
các bạn và cái gì và cái kiểu file Tức
là mình sẽ ví dụ đây là xanh tiến xa hơn
là sẽ copy tất cả các file đấy và tiểu
file này đến cardspace cái các bạn phải
tiếp theo là destinations đây là cú pháp
của cái câu lệnh là copy file ạ lại gọi
deadly Race in Sài Gòn kéo sang bên này
màu tím Dead Season 2 bằng gì chính là
đường dẫn cao đẳng cấp trên sân bay nhận
đường dẫn thư mục đích hãy Ok Để như vậy
là mình đã xong mỗi câu lệnh Copy
khi bật sau khi mà copy xong mình thể
hiện với thông báo là em hết vóc là còn
cái gì ạ hiểu trả copy các file các bạn
cách này Cái gì ạ Và với cả gì mình đi
là đường giận đường dẫn thư mục nguồn
Theo các bạn và này em gọi mở ngoặc kép
ra là tới đóng hoặc em lại không lại bà
với cả diện đường dẫn thư mục đích Speed
này tức là nó chỉ hiện cái thông báo ra
là đã copy các file không hiểu các file
ở đây mình thêm từ nữa Ok Bây giờ mình
chạy nhé tiếp theo mình chất tạo với bụi
tiền đấy các bạn mở rộng cái cửa sổ mới
ra đây mình vài giờ này và chọn cái hình
mình sợ hình mũi tên ở đây nhá chọn mũi
tên xuống để
Uh cho nó đẹp hơn không không ấy sáng
tạo cái bát đây mình cá nhé các bạn vẫn
vào đi của lớp ơn các bạn chạy giật bác
xem ở đây tao mình gan đang bị gán với
cái chương trình là có wifi ở đây Bây
giờ mình sửa tên nhá copy Ok Bây giờ bác
Bạn tấn chạy em mình thu nhỏ lại mình
thu nhỏ chương trình lại mình mở 2 thư
mục Cài lên nha bây giờ ví dụ mình
xao.sa sẽ là mình copy toàn bộ các file
này các bạn chạy the bước này nó bị lỗi
à các bạn mở lên đây chấm for axit ở đây
cái chữ S đấy các bạn thiếu chữ s nhé để
cậu trên df vào đây bao giờ mình chạy
lại nha mình ra ở đây ok nó sẽ hiện ra
thông báo là đã có bị pha như vậy là
mình đã hoàn thành nha các bạn bơm Ok
phải gọi kiểm tra nhé đoàn kết thư mục
đích đây đã có tất cả các file rồi đấy
đã bị xóa lại đi nhé bây giờ ví dụ mình
chỉ copy và Excel thôi vì sao chấm x lời
hạt nha hoặc xls đi lại thì ví dụ ở đây
là excel của mình là phidex chả hạn nhé
thì nó sẽ copy 2 file Excel này thôi bên
mình kiểm tra các bạn cần có copy Ok nó
sẽ hiện thông báo là đã khóc vi xong và
các bạn nhìn ở viết thư mục đích cho có
2 file Excel luôn lại ví dụ bây giờ mình
chỉ copy file mà Doctor Coffee thì nó sẽ
copy thêm 2 cái file ghost này Qua đây
mình bị xóa cái này đi với các bạn quay
lại là copy hết nhé Thì biết xao.sa
không lại Ví dụ mình tạo với file pdf ở
đây đi nếu file này phải chấm Tech được
nhắc mình tạo khoảng cách ở đây là test
đây thì xa Tiến sao đây nó sẽ copy thêm
khai test này bất kỳ file nào nó cũng
khóc vì hết các bạn thích và Copy lại Ok
gọi thấy nó sẽ copy
sản phẩm bao gồm cả các file test vừa
sang một mình tạo luôn ok đấy bên Ví dụ
mình thế thôi một góc đấy nhắc Ví dụ
mình phạm cái thư mục bất kỳ Mình ghi gõ
là lái xe hạn nhé đây là kết thúc cuộc
đời thực tế là không tồn tại phải thì nó
sẽ báo lỗi cho các bạn này các bạn thích
của copy để nó sẽ hiện với thông báo
không tồn tại thư mục nguồn lại máy giặt
sửa ghế thư mục đích mà mình đánh gái
sao thế là không tồn tại thật thì nó sẽ
báo lỗi là gì ạ là thư mục gốc không tồn
tại đấy cả Thế em không tồn tại thư mục
đích ở đây mình cảm thấy bác tuần trước
và đi chợ hoặc các bạn có thể vào
developer này mình Insert cái bát hương
ở đây cũng được thì các bạn nhận lại
mình chưa dán gội mình bấm cancel đây ở
đây mình đánh phải này mình vào idteck
đã bị xóa lại đi mình sẽ gái là
Ai Cập nhật đây là chỉ là tên các bạn có
thể đặt tên bất kỳ gọn buồn nhé Bây giờ
giả sử đăng nhập của nhân viên mới nhất
là nhân viên số 2 này họ tên là gái
Excel kế hoạch là 12 mục tiêu là mười
năm đấy Bây giờ chúng ta làm cách nào để
phân tích và cập nhật đây thì dữ liệu ở
bên này nó sẽ điền vào tiếp khách hàng
tiếp theo thì cái này có cái trộn là gì
Các bạn chú ý nhé khó cái chỗ mà khi bạn
copy dữ liệu cái đấy thì nó xem nhảy đến
cái ô tiếp theo vào nó không Nè Thấy dữ
liệu cũ thì nó nâng cao ở chỗ đấy nhá
Thì đầu tiên các bạn vẫn chọn với các
macro cho mình ở đây mình sẽ đạt được gì
ạ Ví dụ mình đang làm gì cập nhật dữ
liệu lại có thích Ừ ok thì đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ hiểu các bạn Bôi đen Cái phần này
không ạ copy các bạn giới thiệu phải
copy nhé xanh cái sĩ data này đấy thì
đầu tiên Các bạn nhớ là các bạn thích là
cái ô đầu tiên cho mình ở đây là Ova 3
Tức là cái hàng đầu tiên cột đầu tiên
của mình nha
anh không các bạn giữ cần trôi mà mũi
tên xuống không các bạn sẽ chọn một cái
là gì ạ Các bạn thích và cái u realities
print tức là để lần sau mình có nó sẽ tự
động dịch xuống một tích và cái này thì
gọi thích Xong để còn thấy biểu tượng
đấy nó hơi hình thâm thâm đâu mà mờ đây
này để sau bạn ấn mũi tên xuống để
nguyên xuống đây không các bạn nháy
chuột phải này các bạn chọn be special
mình chọn Transfer transport là gì mình
sẽ chuyển dữ liệu cột thành hàng hoặc là
hàng thành cột Tức là mình sẽ chuyển
ngược lại ở đây mình ok sau khi mình
tích ok xong thì gọi tích bỏ cái yêu
graet gel fol này lại xong mình sẽ quay
lại nút để bị xóa các dữ liệu này đi bây
giờ mình stop ghi nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ
nháy chuột phải vào cái bát từ này để
mình dán macro lại ở xa Mát rồi mình sẽ
dán vào cái mắc luôn là cập nhật dữ điện
Bây giờ mình Bây giờ các bạn nhìn thấy
rồi đấy nha
Có xe rồi đúng không Bây giờ mình đi
được cập nhật số 3 ở đây là gì vĩ độ đây
lại xem chỉ cần đi kế hoạch là ví dụ 20
mục tiêu là mười thế nào Bây giờ mình
thích hoặc cập nhật để gọi thấy ở đây nó
đi Xóa đi mà ở trong cái phần data này
nó là cập nhật đến cái người thứ ba đây
lấy ví dụ mình nhập người thứ tư nha lại
từ từ này họ và tên là gì Bạn Nguyễn Văn
A kế hoạch là gì những loại nhà chín mục
tiêu là 19 hạn hãy đã tích hợp cập nhật
xanh cây đao ta này đã cập nhật được
nhân viên thứ tư trong cái này các bạn
rất chú ý cho mình này mình phải sử dụng
cái yêu reality gel này thì nó mới có
tác dụng nhé Còn cái control và mũi tên
xuống vào đây tức là khi cất khi nào
mình có thêm một cá nhân viên mới thì
mình bấm cần Chu là mũi tên xuống vào
đây này thì nó sẽ xuống miệng cách hàng
cuối cùng tại sau đó thì mình sẽ sử dụng
cái abilities này để nó sẽ
và tiếp theo đây là như thế nhá Tìm kiếm
mình sẽ sử dụng là fnfilter okay đây là
dữ liệu bắt đầu bây giờ mình sẽ tạo
table bằng cách Các bạn bấm cần sơn t
nhá Hoặc là các bạn thích và Insert này
lại các bạn tin là tê bồ đây hoặc Bạn
bấm phím tắt là cần Sơn Tây ở đây này
lại Ok thì nó sẽ mặc định Napoleon tất
cả các vùng dữ liệu này của bạn từ B2
đến j23 các bạn Nhớ thích chọn là mai
table khác hết đời nhé Hãy gọn Tĩnh Okay
đây sau khi các bạn tạo Thay bồ này Các
bạn nhìn thời gian các bạn có thể đổi
cái hình mỗi cho nó đẹp Sau đó thì mình
sẽ đặt tên tây-bồ nha Cái thêm bột là
tên mặc định thì mình có thể đặt tên là
lẹ dữ liệu cũng được lại các bạn enter
như vậy Mình có một cái table là tên là
dữ liệu rồi nhá Bây giờ mình quay trở
lại cái tìm kiếm thì kệ Phan Kim Cương
vẫn chú ý nha các bạn phải làm trong cái
sĩ Tìm kiếm Tại vì khi các bạn copy dữ
liệu nó chỉ có
Em hãy tiếp tục là mình làm ở sim nào
thì mình mới dùng được phép tăng filter
chiết xuất và chiến sĩ đấy thì đầu tiên
nhé để làm at Manchester là đầu tiên các
bạn phải các macro này các bạn và
developer này mình bấm record macro mình
sẽ đạt ở đây là gì mình sẽ đặt là s
Exciter đi mình sẽ đặt nghệ vàng inter
tới là lọc nâng cao đấy theo mình thích
ok thì đầu tiên gọn thích với Đây nhá
tính cả cái ô dưới cái thông tin này các
bạn vào S3 gọn Tok này thì ở đây trong
clip Jane của mình thì mình tìm ở cái
vùng danh sách tôi chứ không phải là
trong ở đây thì bạn thích vào đây trong
mình sẽ quay lại danh sách lựa chọn bố
đen tất cả đây nhá Khi các Model có bạn
thấy ở đây nó sẽ đổi tên thành dữ liệu
ôn lại thức làm cái Thay bồ của mình là
ôn họ là thích và cái mũi tên này thì
sang cái phần thứ hai là cái tiêu chuẩn
lọc nhé Đây này các bạn sẽ Bôi đen cho
mình
mục tiêu đề và mô đen khách hàng dưới
nước tức là từ OB B2 đến oxy 3 lại tiếp
theo là mình sẽ tích và việc copy tụ naq
đây này phải không các bạn tích và cái ô
ô copy tung đây là thích Và tôi kết quả
dưới này để tức là sau khi mà nó sẽ tăng
thêm tơ thì nó sẽ copy dữ liệu vào ô kết
quả dưới này hoặc bạn thích và ok đây
Thì như vậy là nó sẽ copy Tất cả dữ liệu
xuống dưới ở đây cả thứ nha Phía đây là
trắng nó ra nó sẽ copy toàn bộ dữ liệu
tại bây giờ mình sẽ quay trở lại lại đi
với rapper và mình Stark ghi bây giờ
mình sẽ tạo nên bác Tưởng ở đây để mình
thích nhất thì bạn có thể vào Insulin
mình chọn cái bát đường vào đây mình sẽ
đặt em nháy cho phải các bạn gọi E
reflect này mình sẽ đạt là gì ạ Tìm kiếm
đi hay là lâu cũng được tìm kiếm dữ liệu
lại
em có thích lúc này mình cho căn giữa
đây mình cho căn giữa đây có thể vào
format mình đổi lấy hình này thì các bạn
mong muốn nhé ví dụ mình để hình ai đấy
Bây giờ có nháy chuột phải này các bạn
ơi sao macro mình sẽ dán vào tiếng macro
là s enta này Đấy tức là khi mà mình
không nhập gì đây thì nó sẽ in toàn bộ
dữ liệu ở đây cho các bạn bây giờ ví dụ
mình tìm với các thứ nhất mình phải tạo
một cái con macro để mình xóa các dữ
liệu ở đây đi Tức là mình xóa dữ liệu cũ
đi Nếu mình muốn tìm mới nhé bạn dễ
cancel và chữa cháy và kéo xuống đây lại
rất là mình sẽ tạo với bác Tư mới và các
bạn theo Sẵn đây cũng được để gọn nháy
chuột phải hết ak để mình sẽ đây mình đi
để xóa dữ liệu xóa dữ liệu cũ đây Okay
bây giờ mình sẽ tạo có một cái mắc rồi
mình xóa dữ liệu cũ nhé thì các bạn
có nhiều lớp ơi mình gửi các macro này
Đây là diện xóa dữ liệu hiệu cũ ok thì
các bạn sẽ bu đen ở đây này muốn đem từ
đầu đến cuối nhất là các bạn giữ phần
ship giờ quan của mũi tên xuống này
nhưng mình xóa đến hàng cuối cùng nó
chắc các bạn nhé nghiệp phải các bạn đi
mid Mình sẽ chọn là insight ra ở đây tức
là mình xóa hết tương tự ở đây gọi bộ
đen hết ở đây ạ bấm Delete nhá Vâng
Delete trên bàn phím này tóc về Nonstop
này con Linh này về gọi nhé chuột phải
bạn dán nhé để mình sẽ nhá vào thì xóa
dữ liệu Ok bây giờ xong rồi nhé Bây giờ
các bạn thích và tìm kiếm nếu con không
nhập dữ liệu thì các bạn thích tìm kiếm
này Đấy sẽ ra luôn ở đây Bây giờ mình
thích và xóa dữ liệu cũ hãy nhớ hết ở
đây bây giờ ví dụ mình tìm bạn giới tính
là
anh trai vì con trai không có bao nhiêu
con trai của bạn thích ở Tìm Kiếm dữ
liệu lại như vậy con trai của mình ở đây
là có bao nhiêu và 11 bạn bè mình xóa dữ
liệu cũ đi mình tìm là con gái đi hạn
nhé con gái này có thích là tìm kiếm đấy
con gái nó sẽ ra là bao nhiêu bạn con
gái có 10 bạn thôi mình sẽ dữ liệu đi
bây giờ sự mình tìm con gái này và họ là
Nguyễn đấy lại tức là nó sẽ xảy ra đồng
thời nha thì có bao nhiêu bạn lại nó chỉ
có một bạn thỏa mãn cho tôi là Nguyễn
Văn và hiện nay lại Yến con gái còn xóa
dữ liệu nhé bây giờ ví dụ Các bạn muốn
tìm cái bạn nào có tập điểm lớn hơn năm
để nhắc bên mình xóa đi thì mình chỉ cần
ghi ở đây là lớn năm trước mình sẽ tìm
kiếm bạn nào có tập điểm lớn nước 5.000
hạn lại còn thích tìm kiếm đây ở đây
tổng điểm lớn năm có bao nhiêu vậy rất
là nhiều bạn 20 bạn ấy đang năng nếu năm
và là nghiện
phụ nữ đi Chẳng hạn nha gái đi bây giờ ở
các bạn phải xóa dữ liệu ở đây mình sẽ
tìm diện tổng điểm lớn hơn 5 này và điều
kiện giới tính là nữ thì có bao nhiêu
bạn ở đây là gái đẹp này gái trai gái
đấy đây mình thích và tìm kiếm dữ liệu
tại như vậy là giới tính là gái và tổng
biển lớn năm là có chỉ có chín mạng cho
[âm nhạc]
cách để copy nhiều file Excel vào 1 file
duy nhất Giả sử Chúng ta có 3 file mình
vẫn copy nhất bây giờ có bạn mở 3 file
này lên các bạn Bôi đen này gọi bấm
enter phần thứ nhất của mình sẽ có 7
theme tất cả từ thứ hai đến chủ nhật nhé
trong cái file thứ 2 của mình chỉ có một
tên là Z1 này còn trong cái file thứ 32
của mình có 2 xít thì cũng tên là chung
với cả tiền ship một ở file thứ 2 và một
cái tên
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ copy 3 file này gồm
tất cả ca sĩ và một pha nhé chị đầu tiên
mình nhân tạo một file mới được thực
hiện các bạn có file này các bạn chọn
lưu này để mình rất bấm là sao nhỉ sẽ
tàn phai mới hoặc các bạn có thể hướng
chính xác là cần trên n để tên file của
mặc định của nó sẽ là bước 1 túi hiện có
những mạng thì múc 2434 rút ra được tiếp
theo các bạn sức của An đã 11 để các bạn
mở cửa sổ lập trình nhé lại các bạn bấm
F11 để sau đó họ chính Á trong các
Facebook một đây này các bạn xinh nhảy
chuột phải vào Facebook một các xã Yên
đấy Mình sẽ chọn môđun như vậy nó sẽ tạo
cái mô đun ở đây để mình biết cốc nha ở
đây mình đã có sẵn kỹ đoạn cốc rồi phải
mình sẽ nhấn cần phải copy đấy Mình cho
vào cái đoạn cố đề các bạn nghe điện
thoại đoạn kết vào đây các thứ nhất mình
sẽ gửi cái đoạn cốt này trong cái phần
mô tả phía dưới video để các bạn cùng
thực hành nhé Để sau khi các bạn kết nối
bạn cốt này rồi nhé các bạn
anh vào cái folder mà chứa các file mình
cần copy ạ Đấy ví dụ ở đây mình có một
cái cô đơn là copy nhiều file vào một
file để gọi tích vào đây các bạn nhé
điện thoại copy thức là mình sẽ công ty
đường dẫn mà chứa các file cần copy ạ
Hãy các bạn vào phần IV trong các phần
phát là cái đường dẫn này mình đã mở
ngoặc ở đây qua nhé điện thoại thiết kế
đường dẫn của cây thư mục và chứa các
file cần copy nhất trong các bạn bấm
thêm một cái gạch chéo ra để Excel nó
hiểu là đây là folder Ok Bây giờ có thể
chuyển chạy được có chửi nhắc một số bạn
mà để bên cái file này ở folder khác thì
bạn phải thay cái đường dẫn ở đây quan
trọng nhất ở đây là cái phần đường dẫn
ra các bạn cập nhật theo cái dữ liệu và
các bạn muốn copy bây giờ các bạn bấm
gian ngắn hoặc phím tắt là F5 này còn
chồng lúc đấy nó sẽ copy toàn bộ các
peptit của 3 file mà mình cần copy vào
cái file Mình mới tạo là Facebook bộ để
về gọi chú nhé đây từ chủ
Ở đây còn cái đã Nói chung Tết thì nó sẽ
tạo một cái tên của nó nằm ở ngoặc thứ 2
và thứ 3 tức là có 3 fife ít một bị
trùng tên còn những Axit khác còn nó
không bị trùng thì nó sẽ giữ nguyên nhé
tiếp theo thì mình có thể tạo một cái
bát Tâm ở đây để các bạn tích và các bạn
chạy được đấy đây mình sẽ tạo hình ảnh
còn rực chả ra các bạn kéo nhé Nháy chất
phải mình chọn tiền antech mình sẽ ghi ở
đây là copy nhiều file và 1 file có thể
gõ gì cũng được ở đây là chỉ đặt tên để
các bạn hiểu mình tăng giữa nhé gọi là
Thì hôm này đang giữ đây mình có thể thu
nhỏ này lại để tiếp theo các bạn nhé
chuột phải vào cái bát tượng này các bạn
chọn hơi sai macro có thích của việc
coppy file này để cách copy file chính
là cái tên cốt của chương trình là có
Wifi đấy thì nó sẽ tên ở đây là trùng
với cái tên để spotify đây này các bạn
còn Ok Để như vậy là tớ bắt lần này khi
mình tích vào đây thì nó sẽ chạy cái cốc
Em thích thường lần nữa em về nó sẽ copy
thêm một lần nữa đấy thì gọi truy nhé
như cái sít này nó lại nghĩ Trùng 2 lần
thì nó sẽ thêm số 2 ở đây đấy nó bảo là
bị lật lại hai lần mà mình có thể xóa
cái này đi nhé các bạn giữ xít này và
đến vị trí dưới đây không còn nháy chuột
phải thoại đi các bạn mất lại cái ship
một là VSIP ban đầu được nhé để các bạn
giữ ship đến Nghệ sĩ Cuối Cùng Ở đây còn
nghe điện thoại bạn muốn delete Ok Để
như vậy là còn là cái sim này duy nhất
bây giờ các bạn bấm cân cho nhé Để qua
lưu với file này lại nhé các bạn có thể
lưu và các thư mục nào có bạn mong muốn
nhá Giả sử Mình ở desktop viện để trong
phần này gọi thứ nhất mình phải lưu file
dưới dạng diện Excel macpro anavel
Facebook này thì nó sẽ không bị mất đoạn
cô đơn còn nếu các bạn như lấy ra thích
xem thông thường là xnxx thì nó sẽ bị
mất cố định họ sẽ lưu đặc điểm có y phim
sex ok Bây giờ có gọi chuyển chạy cái
này là sao
em rất hay thì việc đầu tiên các bạn là
các bạn phải lưu chương trình nhà Ví dụ
mình cân trên at này lưu chương trình ví
dụ ở đây mình lưu là desktop bạn chú ý
nhất ở đây mình phải định dạng là mắc rô
này ví dụ các bạn đã đặt tên là gì ạ tạo
hàm đi tạo Hàn riêng đúng đấy làm riêng
nhé đầu tiên các bạn sẽ vào developer
lại các bạn thích và ghi rồi music để
trong các bạn và Insert các bạn chèn một
cái mô đun để bạn biết tốt nhất thì bạn
chú ý cái hàm này các bạn phải viết cho
mỗi đôi thì mới được đầu tiên mình sẽ
chú thích tên của chương trình Nha tự
tạo hàng riêng trong Excel vba rất là
điện hàm riêng các bạn thủy nhất hành
riêng có thể Tức là cái Hàn mà không có
trong Excel Ví dụ như hàm Vlookup là
Excel
Ừ thì mình sẽ không cần tạo nữa mà mình
tạo những cái hàm mà cho mục đích riêng
của mình thôi thì đầu tiên mình để tặng
hàng riêng hiện nghị Bạn viết là tăng
cường nặng tăng Dừng tiếng Anh nghĩa là
hàm sau đấy nhỉ tên chương trình ví dụ ở
đây mình cần đầu tiên Gánh Hàng nối
chuỗi nha thì mình biết là nối chuỗi này
đây các bạn mở ngoặc ra không Các bạn
truyền các tham số vào ví dụ đây mình đi
là điện chỗ này s nên phải Tức là mình
đi là ký tự giữa các chuỗi test sinh thì
mình sẽ giải thích cho bạn nhá Khi các
bạn thích tăng dần thì mặc định ở dưới
nó sẽ có một kế hàm evenson nó sẽ kết
thúc một cái hàm Excel đây cho các bạn
thì các tham số để nghĩa là gì Ví dụ ở
đây các bạn hay có cái hàm Vlookup
khi đến hạn Vlookup nó có bốn Đây gọi là
400 số Z thì bốn tham số này là tham số
và mình truyền vào thì tương tự như vậy
thêm cả một cái hàm trong cái bia thì
mình cũng truyền các tham số này vào thì
khi đó mình có thể thay các chuỗi là cái
ôm mình cần nối lại với nhau còn nên kí
tự đặc biệt ở đây chính là cái ký tự
nuôi chuỗi Ví dụ mình là cái dấu cách
của mình thì để làm cái cái này các bạn
làm như sau nha các bạn thủ như cái tên
hàng vào đây các bạn không được để chung
với cái hành Excel ví dụ các bạn đặt tên
hàm Vlookup là không lên nhá tên hàng
theo mục đích của Mình tên Hào không để
lúc cách nhau lâu ví dụ các bạn cách nối
chuỗi được cũng được nhé Nó phải là viết
liền nhau ạ thì tốt nhất các bạn nên để
chuỗi ký tự mà viết liền nhau và theo
mục đích của mình Ví dụ mục đích của
mình là nối các chuỗi với nhau mình sẽ
ghi là nối chuỗi ở đây mình không phải
là chuối mà là ví dụ mình đặt là gì Em
vào đây mình đặt là phạm vi điện lại
phạm vi rất là gì Tức là cá tôm mình cần
nối lại với nhau ở đây mình xin trình
bày ý tưởng như sao nhanh ví dụ ở đây
các bạn có thể gà
ở Excel phim chào các bạn ví dụ mình cần
nối ba chỗ này với nhau thì có bạn thì
các bạn cho một biến chạy nhanh nó sẽ
chạy bao này cứ mỗi một cái ô thì nó lại
nối lại với nhau thì ví dụ đầu tiên U1
thì nó sẽ lấy ô này nó và này bước Thứ
hai là mình bằng để ô Kết quả đây xong
mình và với cả một cái vú kí tự đặc biệt
những du khách này các bạn và với lại
cái ô này trong các bạn đến việc cuối
cùng với bạn lại bằng cái ô mà các bạn
vừa lấy được các bạn và với cả cái dấu
cách các bạn và với cả cái ô ô Cuối Cùng
Ở đây hả Thế thì nó sẽ ra được kết quả
Mình ở đây là gái xe Xin chào các bạn
nhé Đấy mình xin mời qua ý tưởng như thế
thôi ở đây mình ví dụ đầu tiên mình phải
tham gia một cây biến là biến rim là mỗi
ký tự tên biến là các bạn có thể đặt tên
bất kỳ được tốt nhất là
kể từ đó có ý nghĩa ở đây mình chẳng nói
lên đi Tại sao lại lên để nói chung với
cả triệu biến của các biến phạm vi này
sau khi mà các bạn khai báo biến mỗi ký
tự ở đây thì các bạn sẽ làm như sau
one-fourth này ích của mỗi ký tự này có
bạn trai cho Speed này im phạm vi khuẩn
control Speed nó để nó thì theo với
những khi các bạn mà mới làm xong thì
bạn gọi hạt nách luôn tức nào sẽ kết
thúc cú pháp for vào nách luôn để quạt
Đỗ Quyên nhé các bạn ấn áp một cái mình
sẽ tùy vào mỗi ô nhé cách câu này nghĩa
gì tốt là của mỗi ký tự đây này Nó sẽ Ví
dụ ở đây mình phạm vi của mình là bao
này nhá thì nó sẽ quét từ ngữ cô một đầu
tiên là beto get này sau đấy Excel này
trong nó pet lên ô Xin chào các bạn đấy
vì cái phạm vi của mình là bao nhiêu này
mà Thì sau đấy các bạn sẽ gắn thì các
bạn nối chuỗi này các bạn ấn conspire
thì nó tự nó điền các ý với còn lại các
bạn chắc bà mẹ ạ nối chuỗi này nó
Ừ cái gì và mỗi ký tự trong bạn và và
một cái là ký tự giữa các chuỗi Ở đây
các bạn ấn kahchan Super nhá cái câu này
nghĩa là gì Tức là cái nối chuỗi này nó
sẽ luôn luôn đầu tiên nó sẽ bằng rỗng
sau Đấy nó sẽ và đầu tiên là và với cái
chữ gà này sau đó là Và với cả dấu cách
ví dụ đấy cái ký tự giữa các chuỗi mình
muốn là dấu cách thì nó sẽ gà là cách
nên Excel trong cách xin chào các bạn
đấy ý nghĩa của nó là như thế đấy nhé ví
dụ mình xong cái hàng này nhắc các bạn
chạy thử cho mình nhắc test nhé Nếu Bắc
Cạn thứ nhất sau khi mà các bạn viết cái
Hàn núi chủ được đây rồi thì sang bên
này các bạn có thể gõ luôn được là lỗi
chuỗi các thấy đây là cái hàng bằng mình
tự tạo Excel nó không có đó chính là cái
tên nào nối chuỗi bạn thấy chính là cái
Hằng nó chửi đây này hãy coi ấm áp nhé
thì đầu tiên cái biến mình cần truyền
vào là cái tạm vi thì phạm vi ở đây
chính là ba cái ô này
khi phải tiếp theo là các ký tự mà mình
muốn bao này nó cách nhau ra giới thiệu
mình muốn là dấu cách giữa bao này để
thăm mình đóng lại lấy toàn thấy đầu
tiên nó bằng 0 Tức là nó giống này thì
nó sẽ quét đến các bước này tiếp theo là
các bạn chạy Bố có đấy chạy thì đầu tiên
cái mỗi ký tự này các bạn để nó sẽ bằng
cái chữ gà đầu tiên này nó quét đầu tiên
chữ gà này thì cái nối chuỗi này nó đang
rỗng mà bạn thích một cái nhìn đầu tiên
nó sẽ bằng cái gà xong nó và cái giống
cách ra đấy Bạn thấy không bằng gà đúng
cách như này còn nhìn con dưới đây con
ếch một cái nó quét đăng kí tự thứ hai
là cái nó quen những cái chuỗi ký tự thứ
hai chỉ là cái Maxell này Đấy cái mỗi ký
tự này nó sẽ gán bằng cái suối tiếp theo
là Excel vào đây là kết quả là lỗi chuỗi
xe bằng gái Excel loại vàng cái dấu cách
nữa bạn thấy dưới cái chữ cái xe này nó
không video cách trong loại quét đến cái
ô ô cuối cùng của phạm vi là cái ô Xin
chào các bạn đấy em mỗi ký tự có thể
không nó chính là xin trả
Anh hiểu sếp và đại luôn đấy không Các
bạn bấm đấy nó xong nó đây là kết quả
đây cảm thấy nó sẽ có một cái chữ gà Xin
chào các bạn thì các bạn để ý nhá kết
thúc của cái này nó có một cái xấu cách
nữa Ví dụ ở đây mình kết cao rồi nha bạn
copy này đang đây các bạn hết cao tuổi
cho mình Ví dụ mình biết bao ưu đi hiểu
đấy còn thấy ông nó sẽ giữ một số cách
ra đấy Tại vì là mình và với cái dấu
cách ở đây nữa thì để xử lý cái dấu cách
này các bạn làm như sau nhé sau khi là
kết thúc cây vòng là ho này rồi Nó là
cái chuỗi của mình đã hoàn thành rồi nhá
thì mình sẽ ráng diện nối chuỗi này sẽ
bằng là gì từ từ nhắc quay lại cách SEO
được mình xử lý cho các bạn nhé Ví dụ ở
đây các bạn và với cả dấu đôla đi được
bạn giới thiệu đấy thì đến vì mình chưa
dùng để làm để bụng à
Ở đây các bạn và ba dấu đôla đi khắp thế
tức là cái chuỗi ký tự này nó sẽ cách
nhau vòng 3 cái dấu Đôla và nó thừa ra
ba cây đô la ở cuối đây này thì để bọc
vải 3 cái đôla cuối này có bạn làm như
sau nha các bạn chất bằng bác bạn bằng
lép này Nét Một cái chuối này đúng ạ cần
phải xong các bạn ấy len Tức là mình
được tính được cái độ dài của cái chỗ
này đấy không có bạn - độ dài của cái số
ký tự và các bạn chèn dưới các chuỗi này
Ví dụ ở đây mình là 3 cái dấu và đây này
thì mình sẽ - len của Rin của cái ký tự
như các chuỗi ở đây bản chất ở đây là ba
này thì mình gõ là - body còn hiểu yếu
lắm đấy nó sẽ trả về cuối cùng nó sẽ cắt
được ra là 3 cái dấu lại đây đấy thì cho
nên ở đây mình sẽ dùng mình sẽ gắn như
sao kết nối chỗ này theo bằng viện bằng
ghép này Các Mở nhọn da này Nét chính là
cái ô nối chuỗi luôn này các bạn
top 10 nhạc phẩm không ngừng lấy len của
cái nối nối chuỗi lại cho nên mình
Phương các bạn các bạn lên bắt đầu học
lĩnh Richie và Excel của bạn cũng phải
khá là thành thạo rồi đấy bởi vì mình
phải tương đối tình trạng Excel thì mình
học vui vì nó sẽ thuận lợi hơn rất nhiều
để nhận nét của lỗi len của nối chuỗi
các bạn chiều đi viện các bạn - Red của
gái tên là cái hàm tính độ dài đấy - Red
của ký tự như các chỗ này thì từ các
chuỗi các đống mặc lại như vậy xong nhé
Bây giờ các bạn chạy lại chạy lại cái
hàng này nhé con em tự lại đấy còn thấy
nó không còn cái ký tự 3 cái dấu và lại
nữa lại có thêm rất là hai ví dụ mình
thay cái dấu và bằng đây còn xóa đi Bằng
đến cái ô tham chiếu là Cái ô này chẳng
hạn thế Thì bạn thấy ông đầu tiên với
ôxi này của mình nhé đầu tiên OC này là
chống Nga là các ký tự đây nó sẽ là liền
nhau Ví dụ ở đây mình
ở Sochi này là lúc đấy lại bằng 3 cái
dấu sao đi đấy còn thấy ở đây nó sẽ là
cái sao cách nhau ra lại thì thường ấy
mọi người hãy để là cách nhau một số
cách để kết nối chuỗi nó hay là để như
thế mà các bạn có thể thích các bạn có
để đây là chống phá được đấy thì các
xuống đây nó sẽ cách nhau bằng dấu chấm
phẩy cảm thấy rất là hai ví dụ cái riêng
này của mình là cái hàng nhanh đi thì
các bạn cũng đều làm được mình chẳng cầu
lại đi này ví dụ lạc bộ trí thứ hàng
nhanh này thì bạn cũng bằng liệu các bạn
có thể bằng này bằng nối chuỗi này bạn
Bôi đen tất cả ở đây đấy bạn phải cái ký
tự mình cần lỗi là dấu cách để nó đều
được Ok như vậy là mình đã xong một cái
hàm nói cho con ăn rồi nhé tiếp theo ấy
mình trước sau một cái hàm mới cho các
bạn là hàm gì ạ hàm tính tổng đi Ví dụ
ở Sơn La Thăng sinh tên hàm vĩnh viễn
giận tính trong các bạn ship chưa Ở đây
là tổng này số này quạt đóng mở ngoặc
các loại truyền tham số là gì tham số
của mình là diện chuỗi thì mình đi là
chuỗi hạt này sinh nghĩa là mình sẽ tính
tổng các số trong một cái chỗ này bị
chuỗi này nó là gà Excel 123 đã thì nó
sẽ tính tổng ra là bằng 1 + 2 + 3 ý
nghĩa Đó là như thế Biết chuối này là
mình truyền vào từ từ bàn phím Thế là từ
ngoài vào thì đầu tiên thì các bạn khai
báo một biến là biến rim is-is interior
là gì Ví dụ ở đây mình 123 124 bài hát
nhá năm 56 lần hạ thế này Hello có chữa
bất kỳ như thế này chẳng hạn thế Thì đầu
tiên
thì mình sẽ tách từng ký tự một ở đây
đầu tiên là tái chế từ giờ là công tác
trí tựa này Tái ký tự tiếp theo dấu cách
cách viết tự một nó sẽ quét từ ký tự đầu
tiên đến ý tưởng cuối cùng và nó kiểm
tra xem là ký tự nào nó là số thì nó sẽ
tính tổng đấy quá nhiều yếu ạ thì đầu
tiên mình sẽ giá là gì mình đã là tính
tổng bằng không đi tính tổng số bằng
không đi nghĩa là đầu tiên là chưa tính
gì nhé thì ví dụ để tách ký tự thứ thứ ở
đây là mình tách ký tự 1234 để tách ký
tự thứ 59 giờ số 2 thì các bạn làm như
sau nhé các bạn dùng cái hàm ý đồ này
cái đồ đầu tiên là cái chuối các bạn
cách này đúng không phải là ký tự để
cách tham số tiếp theo của hàng biết đây
là khí tượng bắt được phân tách Ví dụ
mình tách chiết từ năng để hạn chế đúng
không ở đây Mình chỉ lấy một ký tự thôi
nghỉ nói luôn là đánh số 1 để thì nó sẽ
trả về 1 số 2 đúng không ạ Ví dụ mình
muốn lấy chữ e này chẳng hạn như nó nằm
ở vị
địa chỉ nào đấy thì các bạn ở đây để gọi
chí nữa Đây đây là mình sẽ dùng một cái
hàm ít đồ để tách từng ký tự trong cái
chỗ này các bạn hiểu yếu lắm nhỉ Đây
mình sẽ làm như sau nha mình nhận biết
là địa kho đi bằng 1 tool and read của
cái chuỗi đấy thì ví dụ như chuối của
mình là cái chỗ này thì mình sẽ bằng hàm
len để mình kiểm tra xem cái chỗ này nó
là bao nhiêu kiến thức thì nó đang là 21
ký tự thì y sẽ chạy từ những từ đầu tiên
đến cái thứ 21 là Chính là ký tự o này
là kỷ thứ 21 đúng thì kết thúc càng kho
này mình sẽ là hạt nách luôn mình gõ như
vậy cho nó dễ nhớ để mình sáng tác thuộc
vào thì đầu tiên mình sẽ Tức là mình sẽ
tách từng ký tự lạ mình sẽ biết là gì ở
đây mình sẽ tan báo một biến lỗi gì của
từng trí tuệ nặng thế mình đặt một tên
biến là từng ký tự ả
mà SS xinh thì mình sẽ biết là điện từng
ký tự bằng nỉ đúng không ạ từng bạn tấn
Can you speak nhắc từng kí tự các bạn
Việt bằng ni đồ này mở ngoặc đầu tiên là
đây lại lúc đấy mình đã dùng Hàm Nghi
rồi cho bạn rồi thì đầu tiên chính là
cái niệm cái chuối phải tiếp theo là ký
tự thú y đối bạn mình đang cần lấy là
cây in nó quét từ 1 đến 21 thì mình sẽ
lấy từng ký tự một là ký tự Y không phải
một cái là mình luôn luôn lấy hộp ký tự
không đúng ạ lại các bạn enter thì xong
này thì từng ký tự ở đây nó sẽ lấy được
từng nghĩ từ một ở đây mình test thử các
bạn nhé Đây mình tích vào đây này mình
sẽ từ ba cái hàng này mình gõ này bằng
này tính tổng số cao thấy khi mình biết
một cái hành băng Sơn ở đây thì Excel nó
sẽ tự lấy một cái Hàn tính tổng số quả
tấn Tab này thì mình tích là cái ôm này
nhé bạn đóng hoặc bạn Cái ô này lúc đấy
chính là cái chuối chính nhà
ăn chuối mình truyền vào đây nhé ví dụ
trong đoạn enter thẻ thì đầu tiên nó sẽ
tính tổng sẽ bằng không trước này sau
Đấy nó sẽ quét này các bạn ấn ra ở đây
này để đầu tiên y = 1 đúng ạ thì cái
từng ký tự này nó sẽ tách ra sẽ làm một
này còn chặn một pha nữa thì từng ký tự
này Đầu tiên nó lấy được ký tự giây còn
thế hoặc mà ngờ này không này chắc nó
phát nữa thì cần kiếm việc tiếp theo nó
sẽ là chữa lại từng kí tự cảm thấy để
còn thích cả từng ký tự này nó ra chữa
nhỏ đấy nó cứ như vậy Lúc quét đây sẽ
chọn hiểu mình to vậy nha Lại đây mình
chưa làm xong thì nó cứ để nó ra lâu thì
sau khi lấy được ký tự rồi mình muốn
kiểm tra xem từng ký tự này nó có phải
là số 0 thì mình sẽ dùng hàng ít nhé Ít
này nếu như từng ký tự là gì ạ từng quý
vị mà lớn hơn ở Hoàng không Và tôi là
mình dùng là men này từng ký tự mà nhỏ
giọt bằng chiến II
a Cho mình kết thúc cái hàng ăn ít luôn
bạn chủ nghĩa Các bạn gõ hàng thì các
bạn liên kết thúc làm luôn để tránh quên
nhé Thì hai cái hàng này tức làm cái Hà
men này nó sẽ đảm bảo là từ thứ tự nếu
như thỏa mãn hai cái này thì chắc chắn
nó là số rồi bởi vì nó lớn hơn bằng 0 và
nhắn hoặc chín thì nó sẽ nặn số các bạn
chú ý nhé Cái từng ký tự nó tắt đến đây
thì nó lại trả về là là dạng backup
trước mà là số đâu cho nên cái số không
đây Các bạn phải hoặc này đóng mở ngoặc
kép đã đóng mở ngoặc kép này Tại sao lại
như vậy tao ỉa đây ví dụ Chắc bạn nha
Các bạn bằng này biết đây ví dụng các ký
tự thứ 5 Ở đây 5,18 ít đồ là Tết này
phẩy 5 phẩy 1m các enter các thế nó là
số 2 nó nằm ở bên trái này thì nó là cái
thức tách nhưng mà là số để cho nên mình
phải so sánh cái trong dấu ngoặc kép này
mới được các bạn nhé Tại vì khi mình
chiết xuất số ở trong một chuỗi ký tự
thì bao giờ nó sẽ trả về tích đ
Anh dùng cái hàm i5 để mình kiểm tra nhé
khi đang bầu của cái số 2 này nhá Cảm
thấy không nó sẽ trả về phô Tức là nó
không phải là số và nó là tách thì nếu
là nó thỏa mãn hai điều kiện này chắc
chắn nó là số rồi thì bạn bằng hai sao
bạn chết các bạn sẽ gắn điện lúc này là
tính tổng số này các chủ nghĩa cái tính
tổng số là chính là cái tên Hà luôn nhá
tính tổng số sẽ bằng việc tính tổng số
là bằng chính nó trước này cộng với cả
từng ký tự một từ thiện tự Connspeed đấy
sau khi mà các bạn kết thúc cái hàng này
tính tổng số nó sẽ cộng là tất cả các số
đây không như vậy này rất là đơn giản
nhé mình test thử nghiệm bằng tính tổng
số của cái ô này hãy gọi enter thấy nó
sẽ trả về 18 đây cái hàng này rất là đơn
giản mà hữu dụng các bạn có thể tùy và
ứng dụng của các bạn thì các bạn làm nhé
các bạn có thể gọi từ bất cứ đâu cũng
được Tính tổng số rồi đây này Nó sẽ trả
về 18 Ví dụ ở đây mình cập nhật là 123
đi
Ừ thì nó sẽ trả lời 17 Hãy gọi theo 17
đây ví dụ mình bỏ số một đi thì sẽ là 16
ngân hàng Ví dụ mình đánh tên bảy tám ạ
thì 16 cộng 15 sẽ trả về 31 đây ví dụ
đầu tiên ta có 1 file Excel trắng bây
giờ đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ lưu một cái
file nhé chương trình này của mình đi
như là điện Các bạn chọn hiểu pha là mắc
luôn nhé ví dụ mình rồi Khi nào điện gửi
email đi gửi email cho nhiều người đính
kèm file xếp đầu tiên là các bạn phải
thêm thư viện inox trong vba thì mình
mới có thể dùng được chương trình này
đây thì các bạn vào tool này rapper này
các bạn sẽ kéo xuống đến mấy tuần là
Microsoft Outlook để gọi theo Microsoft
Outlook ở đây của mình là 16.0 tại vì
mình cài Excel 2016 tùy phiên
khi xe của bạn là bao nhiêu hãy thư viện
nó là bao nhiêu ví dụ các bạn là 14.0
nghị luận phân tích và đây cho mình làm
mai cửa số cao lớp 16.0 lại Ok trong các
bạn đóng cửa sổ này các bạn Khởi động
lại Cửa sổ đầu tiên mình chất tạo với
môđun để nguyên liệu trình nha các bạn
vào nhiên sợ hãi Các bạn chọn mua đôi
đây mình sử dụng tên chương trình xác là
gạt sen email bạn đóng mở ngoặc hạ
Chương trình này các bạn có thể làm đặt
tên bất kỳ các bạn có thể đặt tên tiếng
Việt là gửi Email cũng được và các bạn
đạt được gửi thư được ok đầu tiên các
bạn phải khai báo biến đầu tiên mình sẽ
ghi chú là ví dụ Đây là chương trình
chương trình này để gửi nhiệt gửi mail
cho nhiều người bao gồm file đính kèm để
mình sẽ ghi chú chích là mình sẽ ghi này
chú là tên nhưng trên nhàng dùng để làm
gì đầu tiên là các bạn phải gọi ứng dụng
cao lúc ra nhá các bạn ứng dụng cụ Crop
các bạn thứ nhất để các chương trình này
mà chạy được vị trí các bạn thực vật cao
lúc trước đấy để chiếc động nếu các bạn
không vậy đó lúc các bạn sẽ không gửi
được đâu ạ thì các bạn làm như sau đầu
tiên các bạn phải vào biến rim này Hà
Nội áp chữa thời gian viết tắt nào lúc
các bạn có thể đặt tên bất kỳ được ạ thì
mình hay quen đặt là olf bạn thì lại ép
gì ạ iroot.apk sân sau đó các bạn xe dán
các bạn test này olf này bằng điện clear
pact các bạn ứng Connspeed được nhắc nhé
này các bạn mở ngoặc này mà 1 kép này
Download application quạt đóng ngoặc kép
và nó bằng đơn lạnh tiếp theo là các bạn
phải gọi một cái ứng dụng email gọi ứng
dụng mail nha các bạn cũng tương tự các
bạn zin này Download new SZ s
khi chấm Nêu tên cho các bạn gái nhận
xét vào lốp mail bằng điện bằng App là
chấm clip item này các bạn mở ngoặc đơn
giai đoạn năm xuống đây A lốp Nếu ai đó
nhắc lại để như vậy là hai câu lệnh này
cái này Đầu tiên là để gọi ứng dụng cao
lúc nhá câu lệnh này để sử dụng email
lại của áo lúc này bắt đầu các bạn làm
như sau nha các bạn tiếp theo bắt đầu
chúng ta này gửi mail này thì nghe thì
đầu tiên các bạn ghi là gì lốp mail.ru
là mình gửi đến ai nhá tô Ví dụ bàng ở
đây là gì ạ là do mình gửi cho mình nhận
hàng còn nhiều chấm com qua đó nhà khép
lại tiếp theo bạn Download new chấm điện
sắp Jack nghe cái tiêu đề đấy bằng cái
gì ạ
Ừ nếu đã đăng ký Kênh là thích Excel để
học Excel Nga để học Excel để trả lại
nhớ ví dụ Download này nu.net body là
cái nội dung email đấy Nhìn ghi bằng
điện bạn Hello vua trên thể nào live
mail chấm thang đầu tiên là chọn người
nhận mail này em là tiêu đề của Male
Body và cuối cùng là gửi email vào đầu
mình chạy nhanh lên mình bận áo lúc sợ
nhất bắt đầu nhấn chạy này Đấy khi chạy
Xong Các bạn nhìn thấy cái áo búp bê là
một là nó bắt đầu gửi thư đến đây còn
thế mà gửi cho Lego morning này tiêu đề
là đăng ký Kênh gái sao để học Excel này
và body là halliwell đang bắt đầu gửi
đấy Ok như vậy là đã gửi đi rồi nha mình
đã inbox
tư vấn VSIP ở Đà Nẵng để tạo theo nó ra
nhận được này Đầu tiên là tu là chính là
cái địa chỉ người nhận ở đây và đây là
sắp nách là đăng ký Kênh cái xe và nội
dung là halliwell đây mình đã hướng dẫn
Xong cho các bạn là cách để gửi mail rồi
Tiếp theo Bây giờ ta cần gửi danh sách
cho hàng loạt người Nga thì các bạn phải
có một biến nặng ở đây ạ quá chú nhất
cái vòng lặp nó phải trước cái gọi ứng
dụng email này này này thì mình sẽ đặt
cái bằng nặng mình khai báo biến nhắn
tin đi em interior biến in này là Yến
chạy để gửi email cho từng người ta cũng
cần phải biến là đếm số người nhắc Ví dụ
mình ghi là miến Điện số người nhận số
người nhận đ
tất cả các bạn hiểu hết số người nhận
Email của bạn chú ý nhất cái tên biến
của các bạn viết liền đấy mình có cái
dấu gạch chân này để đoạn hiểu nhé Thì
mình phải tính đi xuống người nhất như
sau nhé Anh còn lại các bạn dễ nhìn nhé
đấy Bạn thấy với mình đi mình nhập mình
cần gửi email cho hai bạn là access khi
cần và nagisa morning đây thì các bạn
ghi để số người nhận nha số các tăng
cường Face này sẽ gán số người nhận sẽ
bằng viện Excel này chấm Gốc Xi Păng
ting chấm cao cao A để đến nhé K để đến
biết gì đến z Facebook là cảnh tượng
spin chấm diệt Sấm Sét bạn thứ nhất cái
sít này là tên là ship một nhưng mà nó
cũng đã sĩ đầu tiên thì bạn có thể bấm
số 1 luôn số một đấy thể hiện là ca sĩ
đầu tiên chấm chấm chấm rên ư
cho nên này quạt mở ngoặc ra này tên là
gì ạ mở ngoặc kiểm tra b2b đóng ngoặc
kép hai bạn đóng xong để xong làm cao a
để như vậy đến nha các bạn Ví dụ ở đây
bản chất là mình dùng với điện mình dùng
hàm cao a này của cô ấy cột b này Đấy nó
sẽ trả lời 3 thì nó sẽ đến cả cái chữ
email này đấy Nhưng mình chỉ chạy từ cái
từ cái hàng thứ hai thôi thì mình bỏ qua
cái email này thì coi như là ba là tính
cả cái tiêu đề Email thôi lại thì bạn
hiểu cái số người nhận sau khi chạy sang
vào đây nó sẽ là 3 và mình sẽ dùng một
mình riết khai báo hiệu Ford này bằng
hai Tức là mình sẽ quét từ tiếng hàng
thứ hai này thôi Thu hiện tu số người
nhận các bạn ấn conscience nhé đấy như
vậy sẽ chạy từ 2 cho đến ba trong trường
hợp này là 23 tức là có hai email tô
anh ở đây mình kết thúc cái hàng kho thì
llac bạn chửi nhận nick nó phải sau cái
email xe này trong là sau khi gửi cho
các bạn đầu tiên này thì ấy nó sẽ tăng
lên một thành 3 thì gửi cho cái người
thứ hai là raga morning này nếu tu này
các bạn phải đổi cho mình là gì ạ
Facebook chấm net chấm hít hít một ca sĩ
đầu tiên hãy chấm Viettel đêm quét lấy
từ cái bạn Thứ hai này thì là Seo đi
phẩy hai đấy Hai chính là cái cột Oh B2
đây này chính là kế người nhận bia đầu
tiên Excel ích cần nhắc Cái sát nách là
gì xác định ở đây mình nhá là gì mình
ráng là hai các bạn cách ra trong cát và
và tên của cái người người nhận ở đây ví
dụ clear Facebook tiết 1
I shall theo của y phẩy 3 phẩy 3.5x một
bên người nhất ở đây để tên là ký hiệu
đó xảy ra đây là hai gã Excel này thì
cần thế không phải là cái bỏ đi Ở đây
mình đi là gì ạ Có thể ghi là gì mã
khuyến mãi của bạn lạ cận cảnh với nữa
và với việc và đây mình lấy cái cô cứ
mãi là cột số 4 này là Facebook chấm hít
một chấm Cell của diện 2,4 xếp hợp lý
các bạn bật lúc lên đang thì vẫn xem nhé
Bống răng này Đấy thấy chưa các bạn ở Úc
hay thức là ra gửi cho hai người đây
mình bảo nhìn thấy là gửi cho navas
morning và
chị xem chấm thi cân các bạn mã khuyến
mãi của bạn là CD 456 c d e 456 ở đây là
abc123 Ok như vậy là đã gửi sau nhé Bây
giờ mình vào inbox mình freeship này để
đoạn Thấy Naga morning hay Lego và mã
khuyến mãi của bạn là ddf456 bao giờ
mình thử vào email của Excel tiết cần
mình chấp nhận để có thể nhận được email
đây hay gái Excel mã thương mại của bạn
là abc123 đúng với mã khuyến mãi của gái
xe thì là abc123 còn Naga là CD 456 Ok
bây giờ ấy bước tiếp theo mình để làm
sao mình thực tế thì cái body của mình
không phải là như thế này đó ạ body thực
ra có thể là rất dài Ví dụ ở đây nhá
mình cho một cái body khác đi ngay ví dụ
cái body của mình nhé mình sẽ ghi lại
xin chào trong là mình sẽ chào tên ở đây
mình sẽ thay ở đây là thay tên ở cái ô ở
đây
và sau đó thì mình sẽ gửi nội dung mã
khuyến mãi của bạn là thằng làm gì hết
Gửi cái mã này và bao gồm cái file đính
kèm mặt nạ Ở đây còn cách sau đây Lát
nữa mình sẽ giải thích cho bạn sau nhé
toàn diện với với bạn nhận đầu tiên mình
sẽ thay cái tên là xin chào gái trèo đây
mã khuyến mãi của bạn làm mình sẽ lấy mã
đây để vào file đính kèm mình sẽ lấy ở
cái 2 này tiếp theo đến cái bạn nhận thứ
hai thì mình xin chào đây là la do và
mạnh khuyến mãi của bạn là ddf456 và
file đính kèm là Khánh hay nhé Lấy cách
trong này thì từ bắt nó làm mã tml để nó
in bố dượng 05 định sẽ giải thích cho
các bạn khi chạy chương trình như sau
Nga như vậy Ở đây Nghĩa xong được cái
vòng lặp kho rồi bây giờ mình dán Làm
sao để cho cái mỗi động được cái abcd
này thì cái inner Thu này là không thay
đổi này lại tiếp theo là cái sắp nick
này xa
Ừ thì là ví dụ 2 đây mình chào tên tôi
làm gì sẽ ghi này và thêm một cái nhé ví
dụ như là mình thông báo cho người nhận
là gì Ví dụ là gà Excel để hạn gửi mã
khuyến mãi cho bạn sau là tớ bỏ đi ở đây
thì bạn chú ý nhé Thì bỏ đi Ở đây lúc
đấy ví dụ mình đặt cái ô bỏ đi cái mẫu ở
đây chính là cái ô gì hàng thứ hai và
cột giây là cụ thứ mấy năm 67 lại cuộc
giờ là cụ thứ bảy nhé Đây nhé để sử dụng
cái bố đậm thì phải dùng như sau ol là
Nêu chấm dứt body phòng các bạn ứng
connspeeds mình chọn làm body format
bằng miệng đây mình sẽ chọn cái đầu tiên
là format HTML các loại tác vào đây xong
là gì ạ Ở đây mình phải thứ nhất các bạn
của chúng mình biệt đổi cái tên này thế
nào với một cái bạn tên là gái serre thì
mình phải thai được tiêm vào đây lấy ví
dụ mình hàm
em làm thuốc Thúy Sơn các bạn nhiều nhé
các bạn dùng hàm sát vital này đầu tiên
cách khách Cần thay chỉ là Cái ô này
phải cái Âu Tech chính là cái thay tên ở
đây thì mình sẽ khi nhà điện thay tên ở
đây z để cái này là mình để hơi già cho
con hiểu thôi các bạn có thể để là x x x
thì viết sẽ ngắn hơn để phần cái lưu tax
là gì newtech chính là Cái ô này để các
bạn xem đấy thay cái tên bằng phi ô này
luôn ấy phải cái ít hơn người mình để
trống Tức là mình sẽ thay ổ này đây Đấy
mình enter một cái không Thế hai cái chữ
nhật thay tên ở đây nó sẽ thay bằng chữ
là Anh xem tiếp theo thì mình cũng thay
tiếp cả cái mạng khuyến mãi thì các bạn
có thể dùng 2 Hàm sắt thay cầu này giống
nhau cũng được lại thằng bạn phải ở đây
này Ở đây tiếp tục mã khuyến mãi các bạn
sẽ thay cái mã khuyến mãi phải bằng lấy
bằng lái Ô Mart khuyến mãi ở đây quạt
đóng ngoặc hai cái hàng
anh cảm thấy mình ko lại nha đây nó sẽ
thay thay tên ở đây bằng gái xe còn thấy
gái xe và đây mã thương mại thay bằng
ABC là thì mình sẽ dùng hai hàm xách tay
từ liền nhau để mình thay đổi tên và mã
khuyến mãi cho từng người khác nhau ở
đây nhắc nhở đây mình khai báo thêm một
chế biến nữa Ví dụ mình hay một cái báo
nghĩa là riêng này 3dmax ít estus ra
kiểu chuỗi thì mình sẽ gắn đầu tiên thì
sẽ gán là body Mass in ấn cân nhắc để đỡ
phải gõ nhiều bàn ghế Facebook này cho
mít một này đi xe của O2 thứ bảy Đấy tức
là mình sẽ dán cái thất lưu cần gửi bằng
cái ô này để sau đó Mình chia tay nhé
quản Thúy Nga ở đây rồi sẽ thay này à
top 10 mẫu người Chừng nào có bạn
Singapore đi ngay sếp thương Supper này
bằng gì bạn thứ nhất để dùng hàm trong
vba thì các bạn không biết mình hết hạn
bây giờ các bạn phải có cái chữ Excel
chấm lỗ khí tăng dần Sau đó các bạn nên
dùng hàm như huyết sa bình thường được
để tỉa đề nghị dùng lá Excel này chấm
axit tăng dần này chấm dị đầu tiên đặc
sắc tay cầu thứ nhất nhất các bạn mở
ngoặc là xong lại Excel hàm xách tay cổ
thứ hai lồng nhau để dễ được mình đã
giải thích cho các bạn cây hành cùng
nhau đây rồi sẽ lên vào đây mình biết
luôn cho bạn bạn cần chấm gì sắp title ở
đây lại còn chú ý nhá ở đây thì mình
nghỉ hả Mày hơi già đấy Bạn có thể cách
các bạn ấn xếp - vào đây mình enter
xuống dưới Để mọi người dễ nhìn thấy cái
chương trình tôi thực ra Excel nó sẽ tự
hiểu là các câu lệnh dưới này là dùng
một hàng ở đây đoạn đấy Các bạn nhớ nhà
dấu
du lịch sử ở đây Nếu không có Còn nếu
không thì các bạn cứ viết thế này được
thì nó rất là dài ạ Cái đầu tiên là mình
mở ngoặc cái xách tay từ đầu tiên này
body Connspeed message này phải các bạn
sẽ thay cái gì ạ Ở đây mình sẽ ghi là gì
thay tên ở đây sẽ bằng gì bằng cái ô đi
xuống lúc này chấm hít hít 1.co theo của
y phẩy Đây là cái tên là khổ thứ ba như
thể bạn đấy Bạn đóng ngoặc lại để so với
hàng xách tay tổ một đúng ạ Bạn phải
phải cái xách tay từ thứ hai là mình lại
cần thay cái gì ạ thay vì mã khuyến mãi
khuyến mãi thì rất thay bằng gì ạ thay
bằng viết Facebook lại à
em đang bị xóa này đi mình cho xuống
dòng dễ nhìn nha các bạn thân du khách
thích trừ vào đây là anh là mình viết
xuống dưới này mình rất hay bằng việc
lên Facebook chấm dứt một này chấm điện
sao sao của ai phần mấy ạ Đây mã khuyến
mãi nó nằm ở cột D là của số 4 khi thành
bốn phải các bạn đóng mặc lại để đóng
hàng xách tay từ đây cái cần bỏ đi lúc
đấy mình sẽ dán bằng bìa bỏ đi nghe xịn
Ok mình xem nhé đây Các bạn chú ý nhé
giải thích cho các bạn là có mét HTML
nghĩa là gì trong các ngôn ngữ HTML cách
trong đây nó nằm cái thẻ thì ví dụ cái
gã Excel này ví dụ gái xem nó nằm giữa
cái thẻ cho và cái gạch ngang này cho
đây cũng là kết thúc một cái thẻ này thì
cái chữ cái xe nó sẽ mỗi đậu tương tự
ABCD là sẽ bôi đậm và nó sẽ không in đĩa
trước sau ngoài ra đâu ạ
anh Bởi vì cách xong cái đóng mở ngoặc
đây này ngọn đây nó gọi là một thể thì
các ký tự trong cái kẻ cho ngày thì nó
sẽ là bố đậu và nếu bạn không có trong
thì nó sẽ in bình thường nó không có mới
được đâu giật mình test thử nhé Bây giờ
mình bấm Sandy bạn xem rồi còn queo lúc
đấy đoạn này đang gửi cho hai người đâu
anh như vậy nó gửi xong rồi Bây giờ mình
vẫn t-ship để mình nhận nhé đây các bạn
Hôm nay có morning Thì nó xin cái gì Là
gì trong này để hay là gom gái Seo thì
mặc khuyến mãi như vậy là cái xác chết
là đúng rồi Cái xin chào đây là chơi ít
lắm đâu Như vậy là nó đã đổi tên được
rồi nhưng mà nó chết lợn trong này mình
quay lại chương trình nhé để có được tên
người nhận và mãi mãi thì các bạn cần
phải thêm chữ H tmn
từ trước khi body này tức là mình dùng
cái câu lệnh là Outlook Mail chấm ATM
body đáy bằng thackeray sau đó là gửi
email kế tiếp theo ấy để tách hai thì
gọi là vì sau những bạn em tới xuống
dòng thuế nhé Đây là cái hay cái bạn ở
đây là cái file mà mình đang hướng dẫn
các bạn gửi email cho nhiều người đính
kèm đây thì cái cô đơn mình cần đính kèm
nó nằm cùng cái cô đơn mà chứa viết hoa
mình đang chạy ở đây các bạn thích bữa
nay nhé thì trong cái câu đợt này có 2
cái file con làm 21 gửi cho người thứ
nhất là khoai hay thể ra người thứ hai
cái file này gà trống về mình chỉ muốn
test cho các bạn thấy là bánh kèm với
khoai này thôi nhé Thì để làm được cái
việc đính kèm 2 F2 trong hai người mà
trong cái folder này thì các bạn làm như
sau nhé các bạn quay lại chương trình
này nhìn diện olx.ua ghi thuộc tính là
gì tách bên này à
mà sp một cái file đính kèm thì đầu tiên
là giết Facebook chấm pháp các câu lệnh
chấm phá thành nét về Tức là cái đính
kèm là mình cùng đường dẫn với cả cái
file viết Facebook này không các bạn và
mở ngoặc kép các bạn dấu gạch chéo ở đây
nó trong cái cô được là file đính kèm
lại đóng ngoặc chéo cả bạn đóng ngoặc
kép lại đây Các bạn thấy không Cái
folder Tên nó là file đính kèm ạ nếu ví
dụ tên tên con ở đây là gì Ví dụ file
cho thằng nào thì ở đây các bạn cũng chỉ
như là sai không đấy đi đúng theo cái
tên kho Đợt này nhá thấy thông phát ra
cái gì ạ Các bạn và với cả tên xa tên
file thì chủ nghĩa là tên file mỉ trong
cái cục này sung với cả cái tên file
xong cái câu đời này nhá thì nó mới đính
kèm đúng đấy bạn và với cả gì ạ Các bạn
và mình tên
những hình ảnh nick Facebook này trấn
sheet1 này chấm chấm Cell của y phẩy năm
đúng ạ ạ Thế file đính kèm nó nằm ở cột
e này là cột số 5 Hãy thì mình là khi
nào thằng bạn xem bây giờ mình test nhé
mình bỗng dưng lại quay lại lúc này để
gọi theo ngày hai cái file đang gửi đây
lại đây inbox nó nhận được rồi đấy toàn
thấy nó có cái đính kèm đây là file đây
các bạn Lego morning ở đây đấy tên file
là Khanh đấy nó đã đính kèm được cái
file số 2 Đây rồi và cái tên này cũng
bôi lượng và cái mã khuyến mãi không
được bố lượng bạn thứ nhắc cái phần body
này các bạn có thể thêm bất kỳ với đã
được miễn là cái tên và cái mã thương
mại nó nằm trong cái thẻ cho ngày để nó
mới được hữu xin chào hay là công ty gì
đấy ABC thì lấy công ty gà Excel dưới Hạ
thế nhé
ý thì cái body này nó sẽ tự nó cập nhật
này thẻ lên mình chỉ là xin chào không
Đâu Bây giờ mình quay trở lại cái macro
mình dán một cái bắt tầm vào đây nhé
công thức mình Các bạn nhớ các bạn thuộc
với công thức này nhé để thay đổi tên
nhóm ký tự bằng các nhóm tự mới trong
cái chỗ này để các bạn giao hàng xách
tay tùy vào đây mình cần thay hai cái là
tên và mã tâm mình cần hay thảm sát thay
đồ lòng nhau ở đây đó lòng chè và cái
bát cần ở đây là để chạy chương trình
nhé các bạn và lốp Ơ lại lại các bạn
tích và cái bát thơm ở đây dọn ra đây
không các bạn thích là cái gửi thư chức
năng của mình Dán cái bát lần này vào
cái chương trình gửi thư vừa xong của
mình đấy đấy đấy đoạn gì nhắc các chương
trình của mình là gửi thơ thì mình sẽ
ráng nữa bác tuần này vào cái về tư đấy
hoặc bạn có thể nhấp chuột phải đây và
các bạn say macro thì bạn tích lại mà
cái phần gửi thư cũng được thì mình thay
bác gần bằng bấm Delete để xóa thì mình
gõ
ở đây là gửi nhé Bây giờ mình thì diện
tích là gửi email này nó sẽ chạy được
mình nhé được phải nhé Mình chọn format
protein mình thích là đun ngu này xe tất
là cái cái nút này nó không thay đổi khi
bác co giãn này ra hoặc các bạn xóa hàng
nó đều không ảnh hưởng nhé em yêu mình
coi cái bát tuần này lên màn hình đây ví
dụ mình test lại cứ mãi đây là x y là 12
để ạ Đây là cd45 là Hạnh nhé bên mình
test thử nhá các loại phản ứng và gửi
email không quay lại nhìn thấy Đây này
nó sẽ gửi hai cái mới rồi đấy inbox mình
chứ lại nha Đây gọi thấy không Nó sẽ
thay thế mà mới là cd45 mà nó với mình
vừa nhập vào đây tên vẫn thế và các file
đính kèm đây mình quay lại cái nghêu gái
xe của mình ra là mình kiểm tra nhé đây
Các bạn thấy không nhận được hai em
khi vừa tắt rồi đấy lên mạng mới lấy 12
còn cái file trước đấy là việc mã là
abc12 bác Ok như vậy là mình đã xong
chương trình trong chương trình này các
bạn chú ý nhé đầu tiên là các bạn phải
nhớ các bạn phải ép cái thư viện của
offroad bằng cách các bạn vào tool này
không các bạn vào lesson ở đây mình
thích rồi thì nó sẽ chèn lên đây lại còn
các bạn đây là mười sáu tuổi cái phiên
bản Excel của bạn thì có bạn sẽ là 14.0
hoặc là thấp hơn nếu bạn chỉ cần tích là
được đấy thứ hai là các bạn nhớ đầu tiên
các bạn phải gọi được ứng dụng vào lúc
trong các bạn gọi là cái ứng dụng email
này cái vòng lại các ứng dụng email đó
phải làm trong cái vòng nào và số người
gần nhất ở đây thì chính là cái bằng là
khó ở đây tới việc các bạn có thể thêm
danh sách email hàng loạt ở đây đều được
để file đính kèm trong trường hợp là cái
file đính kèm về nó của cô được khác đấy
thì cốt của các bạn đã chú ý nhất ở đây
gọi chỉ được đúng cái
thế này kết quả để con có thể chỉ đường
dẫn mới theo đúng file đính kèm là các
bạn muốn nhé thì thông thường của mình
bình thường là cái file đính kèm nó sẽ
nằm chung trong các order của cái Mai
chạy đây để sẽ làm trong cái cô đơn là
Khánh kèm này Ok như vậy là mình đã kết
thúc bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn
các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký
Kênh để cập nhật video mới nhất của gà
cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng
học cách xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại
[âm nhạc]
à